this video is sponsored by people like
you without your help this wouldn't have
been possible
[Music]
attack on titan is my favorite story of
all
time being someone that's made a career
out of reviewing great stories from the
east
today i wanted to celebrate the
conclusion of what is in my opinion one
of the single most consistent
thrilling and engaging stories i've ever
read with a special review
unlike anything i've ever made instead
of giving each individual arc or season
its own video like i produced in the
past
for attack on titan i wanted instead to
create one colossal review
covering everything spanning every
character every gruesome bloody battle
and every single arc all in an effort to
see what made this story so fantastic
and to try to deconstruct some of the
ideas author hajime isa yama built this
world with from its emphatic beginnings
to its masterful conclusion
but don't worry while i fully intend on
covering material not yet covered by the
anime i won't spoil
anything concerning that portion of the
story until i first cover
the first three and a half seasons and
once i do i'll be giving any anime onlys
a fair warning before i jump into any
current manga exclusive material
but as you can see by looking down at
the timeline that won't be for quite
some time i've been waiting to make this
video for eight years so cancel
all of your appointments grab your
maneuvering gear and give up your hearts
because today
i am reviewing everything in what i
consider to be among some of the most
impressive stories
ever to come out of japan i'm totally
not mark and this is my colossal review
of hajime isayama's modern manga
masterpiece
this is the cruel the inspirational and
the relentlessly powerful
shingeki nokiojian attack on titan
[Music]
it's commonplace within various online
anime communities to hear the phrase
this show is awesome but only after x
number of episodes
attack on titan requires no such
forewarning
the fall of shin ganshina boasting what
is in my opinion one of the strongest
and most compelling opening sequences a
series of this nature could possibly
have
while also confined to a run time of
roughly 23 minutes
attack on titan runs through my
must-have narrative checklist
with the same speed and efficiency as
someone looking to set the next american
ninja warrior speed record
key character introductions check an
exciting inciting incident followed by
clearly established motivations for the
main cast
check a long term hook check compelling
and easy to understand premise
double check but truthfully these are
all elements that are either rudimentary
fundamental
or won't be paid off until much much
later on in the story so
what did attack on titan do with its
first episode to show people that
it's worth sticking around for well by
finding a way to demonstrate its best
attribute its ability to deliver
a twist and find deeper meaning in the
most unlikely of places
for me attack on titan's strongest
elements were always how it adhered to
the internal logic of its established
world
pulling off twist after twist ascribing
meaning to the most mundane
or trivial of circumstances if you were
to look at stories like one punch man
one piece or my hero academia these are
all
tales that through one way or another
managed to communicate effectively in
their own openings what their respective
stories are about and what a potential
reader or viewer stands to get
out of their material however attack on
titan demonstrating a successful
long-term subversion of expectations
isn't exactly something one can
demonstrate within the confines of a
single episode or chapter so
how did isa yama overcome this he starts
his episode with a flash forward to a
big cataclysmic event and this is an
extremely common technique in
storytelling
start with something impressive to help
garner attention right off the bat
however what makes this an exceptionally
great choice of impactful moment is that
this moment this inciting incident
while being paramount to kicking off the
events that follow also gets paid off
within this same very episode
establishing for new viewers a sense
that they are in safe hands and that if
they go along with isiyama on this
gruesome tragic and twisted adventure
he will prove to us all that from the
very beginning he's known exactly
how he wanted to end this story
one of the major criticisms lobbed
against attack on titan throughout most
of its run has been how irritable naive
and annoying the character of aaron
yeager can be at times
while he does have moments where he
wields all the natural charisma of a
typical shonen protagonist
those moments particularly in season 1
are fleeting at best
and i believe this to be by design
making aaron jaeger in my opinion not
only a terrifically written character
but a phenomenally composed main
protagonist that is tailor-made for this
story
specifically looking at this opening
scene and its aftermath as a whole
it's clear to see a number of elements
are after being taken care of quite
neatly but moreover what really caught
my eye was how it communicated aaron
yeager's character in a rather
unconventional but
incredibly engaging way typically
speaking in traditional shonen
storytelling the main character normally
carries with them some attribute that
makes them special or gives them
agency over the story being told think
luffy's devil fruit power or
goku saiyan genetics in other words
broadly speaking all characters can fall
under two broad character types or
categories
with those categories being reactionary
characters and
active characters neither one of these
categories is better than the other
by default they just offer different
pros and cons to their respective
stories
which means choosing which category your
protagonist falls into is incredibly
important to your series success
the perfect examples of exemplary
reactionary characters in the
protagonistic roles
can be observed through characters like
saitama from one punch man or gohan from
dragon ball z both of these characters
are incredibly engaging in their own
unique ways
but what they share in common is that
their wow or interest factors
come not necessarily from how they
engage with the world or make decisions
but instead how they react to
and subsequently deal with the stresses
the world they dwell within
presents them gohan is put into
situations he otherwise doesn't want to
see and
those stresses cause him to become the
character people remembered him for in
the context of attack on titan mikasa
ackerman is a terrific reactionary
character however when she tries to
enforce her own agency over the
narrative in other words tries to be an
active protagonist it normally doesn't
end well
for her
[Music]
on the other hand an active character
doesn't wait for the plot to arrive at
their doorstep
normally they dictate or make decisions
that bring them closer to conflict
themselves in other words these
characters
drive the plot think characters like
luffy or vegeta
both are very different and offer
different functions within their
respective stories
but both during their runs enact their
own agency
and will that oftentimes create story
progression or
conflict within the plot and this would
be about the time where i would draw
attention to active characters within
attack on titan's world
but i'm not going to do that and that's
primarily because
attack on titan doesn't have any active
characters really to speak of
and the reason why i bring this up at
all is because hajime isayama with the
main protagonist of aaron yeager elected
to write him as an active character
in a world that forces him to be
reactionary
his character structure literally mimics
humanity's struggle against the titans
throughout the first two episodes
aaron's contempt for the lazy the
complacent
and for the titans is there for all to
see clearly with this contempt burns an
intense desire to bring forth change
the world he feels trapped within
however he has
no power and these are the circumstances
isa yama decides to introduce the
inciting incident that will inform the
rest of aaron's life with
suddenly an abnormally tall titan for
the first time in the collective memory
of mankind
peers over those incubating and now
protective walls
before smashing an enormous hole through
the outer perimeter of shin and china
and as a result
any sense of control or security in
aaron jaeger's life
comes quite literally crashing down
around him this
is one of the most raw and brutal scenes
in all of attack on titan forming and
while i'm sure not many would agree
as there are far more brutal or
harrowing circumstances later on
this scene was the catalyst that awakens
an imbalance and anger within aaron that
informs
every single action he takes thereafter
this is the first of many sobering
realizations aaron is confronted by in
the series
and for me one of the most powerful once
again exhibiting his active
protagonistic characteristics
aaron immediately does everything in his
power to free his mother from beneath
the debris
ignoring all the chaos around him even
going as far to instruct the
demonstrably stronger mikasa
to aid in this effort with all hopes
seemingly lost isayama sees fit in this
moment to inject a hint of hope to the
character of hanes
representing thus far in the story
security and safety within the walls
hanas announces that there's nothing to
fear and that he will save aaron his
mother carla and mikasa without delay
this is the moment attack on titan sets
itself apart from most other anime and
so with the small injection of hope and
optimism the story is now primed to
freefall
into the anguish and hopelessness
isayama has set as its target
from the very beginning coming to
realize that he's facing certain death
hanus takes carla's dying wish in saving
both aaron and mikasa
against their will as they flee from the
approaching titan aaron
now with zero agency over even his own
actions
is forced to bear witness to the
horrifying scenes that to this day
are still etched vividly onto his mind
as aaron is forced to look on he
witnesses his mother's struggle
yet killed and ultimately devoured by
the most dangerous entity in this
fictional world in this scene aaron is
confronted by the reality that he
is not strong enough whether it's
through persuasion or physical action
no matter how hard he seems to struggle
he is a puppet that is forced to dance
to the whims of the horrid circumstances
that befall them fostering a deep and
powerful hatred for these enemies of
humanity within aaron to now set his
sights on overcoming and in a powerful
moment that's encapsulated within the
second episode
aaron loudly declares and vows that he
will slaughter every
single last one of them
in this first episode we've learned a
litany of different facts about this
world we've been introduced to and have
gotten to know
all of the main characters to varying
degrees we've been given a strong
motivation a grim set of circumstances
some terrifying antagonists and a carrot
that has been dangled in front of her
collective faces before being gently
lifted away
or has it as an audience we are met with
one horrific incident after the next our
main characters orphaned
hundreds of thousands dead and a massive
chunk of land relinquished to the might
of the titans
now that we are familiar with what needs
to be done and the herculean effort it
will require to successfully reclaim
what was once lost
isa yama introduces us to the next
section of this epic tale
[Music]
the 104th training corps the 104th
training core
arc of attack on titan is for me the
most telling and perhaps one of the
shortest arcs in the series
in this hajime isayama establishes and
emphatically demonstrates without any
uncertainty what the focus of attack on
titan is going to be
it's easily recognized that the manga or
anime industry enjoys school or
training to act as a mainstay backdrop
or primary setting for many of its most
successful stories right off the top of
my head i can think of several that fit
that building in effect there's an
entire industry built around that very
concept due to how successful it is
and it is so for good reason it's
relatable and as such offers ample
opportunity for meaningful
characterization in both the main
and extended cast making it extremely
valuable for a writer to help bond their
reader base with their world of colorful
characters
however as i touched on earlier because
the world of attack on titan isn't meant
to be
comfortable or relatable in this way as
a result it seems as though isayama made
this training arc as short as he
possibly could
lasting only two episodes in the anime
and two chapters in the manga we
followed the progression of aaron mikusa
armin
as well as a litany of new cadets
brought into the supporting cast as they
train and prepare for the day that they
join the military and defend humanity
from the titans there are pros and cons
to this decision and depending on what
you think is more important within a
story
ironically will dictate what side of
this wall you stand one of the major
criticisms leveled against attack on
titan particularly during season 1 was
its lack of meaningful character
interactions and development and i think
it's easy to see why with its regimented
focus on plot progression narrative
slate of hand and thematic messaging
attack on titan perhaps more so than any
other popular japanese story doesn't
bask in or enjoy the benefits provided
by the relatable settings that seldom
present themselves within the story and
this narrative decision on top of having
obvious upsides for pacing and
cliffhanger placement
also yields its downsides which really
only present themselves in any obvious
way when an emotional response is called
upon
later in the story not having spent any
meaningful time with a significant
number of these characters really at
this point
flashbacks to their training days often
depict interactions we never
saw during this point in the story one
clear example of this comes from season
2 wherein jon reflects upon berthold's
apparently strange sleeping pose
nostalgically this creates a massive
dissonance for viewers who want to
relate to what jon is saying
in that moment but can't because for
them
this apparent regular occurrence was
never shared with us during this brief
window into their time spent during the
104th training regiment
however in saying that this doesn't mean
that meaningful character development
isn't
present within this section of the story
at all in fact some of my favorite
developments for characters came from
this very section and it all kicks off
on day one of the 104th
training core despite not having even
cleared that alone perfected any of the
first obstacles in his training journey
when questioned by inquisitive cadets
like connie or thomas about the colossal
titan and armored titan that destroyed
his home
perhaps to aaron's surprise he has to
hold back his shock and tears
before once again brandishing the
persona of someone he wants to be
however this time someone sees through
his act
[Music]
the first person that takes aaron to
task is a confident john kerstein and
he's probably my favorite character from
this section of the story and perhaps
even the entire season
his personality is believable pragmatic
and above all else realistic
making him the perfect foil for aaron's
headstrong and possibly dangerously
blind optimism however
interestingly the initial conflict and
subsequent conversations john and aaron
share comes across as appreciably
different in the manga than it did in
its anime adaptation
in the anime eren seems to dominate the
conversation and sounds the most
convincing however the manga boasts a
much more nuanced perspective with jon
having a lot more to take aaron the task
with citing his dangerous mindset
possibly leading to the deaths of his
friends
and impressionable acquaintances unlike
aaron jean doesn't have
any desire to enlist in the survey core
much less fight titans
he views the walls as very much a
temporary fleeting luxury
to enjoy before their inevitable
collapse in other words he's defeatist
he accepts his circumstances and makes
the best
of it the exact opposite of aaron and so
joining the military police is of
paramount importance to jean
and this is just the first of a number
of significant differences the anime has
made to the source material it's
difficult conversations like this one
with jean that honestly made this
section of the story so enjoyable for me
having seen what ground zero was like
it's interesting getting to see what
other perspectives have
to offer and how what they heard differs
greatly to what actually happened thanks
to sensationalism it's a minor aspect to
the story that goes a long way in
helping create an atmosphere of a more
fleshed out and believable world and how
they affect our protagonist
when reality hits him in the face
this shake in his confidence this sudden
dip in his belief in himself
while fleeting and short-lived grants us
a sobering unnecessary look into the
mind of who aaron truly is
at this time in his life he's now
confronted with the question
what if he can't do this had this been
goku or luffy in the same scenario they
wouldn't have let the setback
phase them in the slightest they would
have just viewed it optimistically as
something they need to overcome
eventually
because that's what their natural
mindset is but for
aaron this confidence he projects is an
act
not just to everyone around him but also
as we saw when confronted about the fall
of shinkanshina
is also something he's lying to himself
about in other words there's a
sprinkling of doubt there the one thing
that sets aaron apart from
everyone else is his desire to achieve
and be the change he wants to see in the
world
and now after having graduated aaron
stands atop the walls of the troths
district
in his eyes he and his fellow cadets
have all transformed from children into
competent soldiers
ready to enact change onto the world
the battle for trust district the battle
for trust district is attack on titan's
most important arc thematically
and what impressed me the most about it
isn't so much its continued shouldering
of the established narrative from the
prior episodes and chapters but
more so how it forces all of us to
collectively wake up to what the real
story being told here actually
is in this arc along with the rest of
the main cast we experience all the same
shock
terror and awe that these characters
we've come to know do
for me the battle of trust isn't so much
the continuation of this story but
instead the hijacking of a brand new one
in the first few episodes hajime isayama
focused on establishing his tight-knit
cast of characters and with the same
loving touch only george r.r martin
could enjoy isa yama forced us to watch
all of those bright-eyed and optimistic
characters face the grim reality of the
cruel world
he's created though much like life it's
not entirely devoid of hope entirely
soldiers like sasha after having been
established in the prior chapters
provide the comedic relief amidst a sea
of tension and anger for me she
represents joy in this series instead of
droning on about the plight of the world
she often in scenes focuses on what
excites her or what she's looking
forward to most
she believes in a future that's
realistic and this scene right at the
top
of the trost arc is my favorite sasha
scene from season one many including
myself upon seeing this scene for the
very first time notice it as aaron's
defining coming-of-age standoff against
the enemy of mankind and the one
responsible for bringing his world to
ruin
and this is quite standard for anime and
as people we always try to search for
commonalities as well as patterns of
behavior that might help us make sense
of new situations
it's for this very reason popular media
is scared to do anything too
experimental why risk doing something
creative if you have something that
works right now and so when i watched
this scene on my very first time going
around
aaron both impressed me and filled me
with excitement as he rated himself to
face off against this world's most
dangerous opponent
the colossal titan however now looking
back at it i love it for an entirely
different reason because it highlights
that there's no one right way to
approach something and that just because
he's the main character it doesn't mean
that the decisions that he ultimately
makes
will lead him in the right direction for
after the colossal titan arrives on the
scene
instead of being in the mindset to look
after his friends or to save samuel from
falling to his death
aaron instead much like everyone else is
in shock
leaving sasha as the only one to save
her fellow cadet from his meeting with
the pavement and
what's aaron's first move when he snaps
out of it accompanied by a fittingly
cinematic and emphatic musical track
aaron attempts to rally his comrades and
charge the colossal titan
alone and it's that attention to detail
and conflict that i adore about
attacking titan
it feels as though when i'm reading or
watching this story that there's a
tremendous amount of effort after going
into communicating every aspect of the
story to me
for instance unlike the other new
recruits that brandish their military
shirts aaron maintains wearing the
shirts synonymous with his hometown of
shigen china reflecting the very reality
of this scene itself and as a subtle
visual indicator of isayama's morally
complicated approach moving forward with
the rest of this mini arc in trust
reminding me of one of my favorite
writers from hollywood
pete docter he's one of the writers
behind films like toy story inside out
and up
and in 2015 pete sat down to discuss his
process and approach to creative writing
and in doing so said something that i
thought captured the spirit of isiah's
approach to writing attack on titan
perfectly
monsters started at about the same time
the kid did as i was working on the film
i was like this is great and then my
wife would say
he smiled for the first time and you
missed it
i want to be in both places but i can't
and that really is what became the story
the sort of
emotional backbone of monsters you know
it's that impossible struggle
with no answer that i think makes for
good stories the more
particular and specific you are in the
storytelling
the more generally it applies right if
you try to generalize then nobody really
gets anything but if you're very
specific
and personal about it it seems to
resonate more
there are no straightforward answers
things do not go according to plan and
even if you work hard to achieve your
dreams it doesn't make you entitled to
achieving those dreams having spent the
last four episodes establishing a tragic
backstory for its main character
a compelling antagonistic force to fight
against and has shown a team of young
likeable characters work hard
training for a better tomorrow in the
battle for trust we learned that attack
on titan isn't concerned with adhering
to tradition or cliche
i am now looking at this scene for what
feels like the 10th time in a row now
and
i can't help but recall the sheer shock
and awe i felt during my very first
viewing of it however looking at it now
while my familiarity with the material
has disarmed its shock value
it instead for me at the very least
hammers homes something much more
important for us as viewers and readers
to take away
having spent years training going
through hell and back
after having convinced all of his
closest friends in the military to give
up their lives of safety in the name of
freedom
aaron yeager watches his entire unit get
taken out
one by one and eaten before his very
eyes and
even though aaron manages to save armin
in one of the most stunning and
tenacious sequences in the first season
he too crumbles to the weight of the
task being asked of him is he a hero
well there's a little more to it those
of you that have seen this whether
you're a fan or not of this moment are
no doubt thinking at this time
yeah this moment was sort of cool but it
gets completely undervalued by the fact
that he comes back a couple episodes
later thanks to a newly discovered
mysterious ability i can absolutely see
this point of view and if i'm being
completely honest
these talking points were certainly
shared between myself and friends of the
series back in 2013 when we were
discussing it however
2021 mark has to strongly disagree
because
whether or not aaron came back aaron
tried his best
and he lost and not just that but he
specifically ignored the warnings
everyone around him offered in favor of
believing that he had some insight that
no one else had when in reality
in the end he wasn't even remotely
enough to change a single thing
beyond saving his one friend and no
amount of getting a second chance can
take away from that fact of the moment
those characters are gone and they're
gone forever he tried his best
and wasn't even remotely enough because
of him a large number of his friends
died and even more have joined the
survey corps putting their own lives at
great risk for the cause he was so
confident he could reach in this moment
aaron is shown to be the dangerous
delusional child
jean so accurately labeled him earlier
in the story a fair distance from the
triumphant hero he was depicted as
seconds prior
somewhat interestingly now that aaron
the main driving force behind the
narrative takes a back seat
the supporting cast gets to explore
their role and in many ways get to lead
the charge in scenes that eventually
today
among to some of my absolute favorites
within this very story particularly with
the characters of mikasa
john and armin these three characters
more than any other are explored in
great detail within this section
again initially upon first viewing i was
excited and interested by the prospect
of aaron acting as a distraction to the
true main character
i suspected in mikasa and when it was
revealed that aaron was to in fact
return
i couldn't help but feel concerned with
how the story would handle the addition
of further exploration into the
supporting cast
know that they had to share time with
erin and on top of that distinguish
themselves while participating in a set
of almost identical problems or
circumstances and so the question became
how do you make these people stand out
well with three characters isa yama
decided to individualize or identify the
three characters by creating very
different emotional problems
for them to overcome rooted respectively
in their past
present and future concerns in what i
originally believed to be
mikasa's main character moment revealing
her backstory instead became a portal
into the day she met aaron for the very
first time illuminating for us these
past scars that inform the person she is
today
bringing to the forefront of the
narrative this struggle she engages with
to find meaning in her life
not replacing aaron but reaching out to
find resolve and purpose in a world
without him
the only family she had left and held on
to fondly it's a telling set of
circumstances and one that speaks
largely into the psyche of mikasa's
character
jean on the other hand isn't haunted by
any scars from something that happened
to him long ago but instead is faced
with figuring out who he is
in the here and now having been
initially headstrong in his decision to
join the military police
john is forced to contend with the
dangers of the front lines is tasked
with leading his comrades to safety
and made to provide answers in
impossible situations to an ever
dwindling group of trainee cadets
beneath him
jean's development is honestly this
arc's shining achievement in terms of
arc progression
i believe taking a once apathetic
soldier and through trial by fire
transforming him into a sympathetic
leader that sees the true value he can
provide to the people in his command
that otherwise would have almost
certainly lost their lives that day
without his ability to make quick and
pragmatic decisions
in this battle for trust jean learns
that he's not destined for a cushy life
in the interior but instead is needed in
the survey corps and it's this struggle
or standing in the face of terrifying
reality and
ultimately a decision that makes jon one
of the most relatable and well-handled
characters in the first season of this
story
for me with the scene he forces himself
to stay when called upon by airwin
acting as one of my favorites not just
in this section
not just in this arc but the entire
story as a whole and finally we have
aaron who much like jean shines like few
others
all the while playing up to the
strengths of his character ever since
being introduced at the very beginning
alongside characters like eren and
mikasa armin has very much struggled
with his sense of self-worth and during
this intense battle armin grapples with
his perception of himself and who he
ultimately wants to be
in the future up until this point in the
story we've dealt with primarily our
established caste and their conflict
against the titan threat thus far in the
series titans have provided a fantastic
antagonistic foil to battle against
allowing isayama to establish and
introduce the main characters and
elements within the story however now
after having familiarized ourselves with
all the necessary trainee characters and
after demonstrating that the enemy is
far greater than we could have possibly
prepared for we finally get a glimpse at
the nuance politics and fear that lurk
within the minds of the broader military
within this world
all the while placing a tremendous
amount of pressure on armin's intellect
and on top of this being a phenomenally
directed episode in the anime that is
just as exciting as any action sequence
with it just being a conversation it
also acts as another terrific example of
world building within attack on titan
which i think is one of its biggest
strengths
whether it be learning how the military
operates getting to know the higher-ups
or seeing people chit-chat on the
streets the battle for trust more than
anything else introduces us to the real
story being told here this is a series
that once it establishes a rule it
adheres to them under real world logic
it doesn't matter who you are or who you
think you are you still need to convince
the minds around you if you want their
help or understanding upon re-watching
this section of the story i was struck
not just by the amazing dialogue from
the main characters but also from the
background characters
episode 6 has a really touching scene
wherein we get a peek into the
perspective of a mother and daughter
saved by mikasa mutterings like the
mother's words comforting her daughter
like
papa will shoot all the titans with his
cannons is small but it does an immense
amount of leg work when it comes to
building up the world attack on titan is
set
reinforcing that there are children and
families behind every single life
lost due to the invading titan threat
and while the battle for trust yielded
many casualties
humiliations and took from aaron his
expectation to say the least
it also offers another element a chess
piece that no one has ever had on their
side of the board
has suddenly made itself visible to them
aaron can now wield the power of a titan
however as i've just shown
it's easy to empathize with the fear
every soldier here is demonstrating
they all have families or something
worth living for why
risk something so valuable one of the
many themes explored during this portion
of the series at large is that of fear
and how people choose to deal with it
for better or worse and an aspect to the
story i relish and adore is how it tries
in earnest to adhere to real world logic
and atmosphere where it can
and few other scenes prior to this one
capture that reality for me in the same
phenomenal goosebump-inducing way
that this scene did all the while we
struggled to make sense of this
situation in real time with the
characters on screen
hoping and praying for armin to pull off
a miracle in the face of certain death
looking at attack on titan i'm sure many
fans might label mikasa as the foil to
aaron within their group
she brushes him the wrong way very often
and she's clearly capable of feats that
he wishes he was capable of however
interestingly upon doing my research for
this video i noticed that along with
aaron being a great example of an
unsuccessful active protagonist
struggling in this world
armin is on the other hand a very
natural and although reluctant
successful reactionary character and as
this series progresses i think it makes
perfect sense how these two end up even
looking at them right now
in this season one unlike typical shonen
protagonists that brandish some
supernatural power
armin arms himself with strategy and
quick thinking in episode 10 similar to
how gohan will be forced into situations
he would otherwise try to avoid
armin is forced to use his superpower
and reacts to the dire circumstances
appropriately whether that takes place
as he and his friends are cornered in a
courtyard or in the case of this scene
helped to orchestrate the successful
recapture of trust armin is quite
literally the opposite of aaron aaron
the eager agent struggling to enact
change in a world that refuses to yield
and armin the reluctant hero that
naturally finds his footing when faced
with the adversity the world presents
his way and for me it was that element
to armin's character that made him the
most relatable person
in the series he's very clearly flawed
and struggling with fear
something that most people can relate to
i would imagine many people might not
closely identify with the relentless
psychotic tenacity of aaron and the
athletic perfection that is mikusa
and watching over the course of this
series as armin transforms from the
skittish nerd to the heroic strategist
is for me one of the most satisfying
experiences and
really the primary reason as to why he
is my favorite character within this
story
the female titan in season one the first
few episodes set up the main characters
and the battle for tross sets up the
broader world within the walls we're
exploring
and then the second half of season one
begins and the training wheels come
flying off
eve of the counter attack the 57th
exterior scouting mission the female
titan and assault on stowheast these are
the arcs that make up the second half of
season 1 and while the aforementioned
sections that make up the beginning of
the series build upon each other and
could work as standalone stories
these new upcoming arcs depend on each
other and work together to achieve a
specific aura for the readers and
viewers
one that i believe is the defining trait
of attack on titan's narrative the
mystery that informs the action
right beneath the surface as i mentioned
towards the beginning of this video a
challenge that isiyama was confronted
with early on was how to best
communicate the strengths of attack on
titan's narrative all within the
confines of a single
opening episode in other words how to
create a short-term payoff
and in the end i thought he did
exceptionally well in solving that
problem but
little did we know the level of
proficiency and
masterful subversive skills that were
right
around the corner unburdened by the
constraints of the first episode's
runtime and the shackles of a typical
shonen plot isayama in this section dove
nape first into the military-themed
kaiju thrashing political mystery
thriller he
so carefully has set up however looking
back on my first ever viewing of this
season in 2013
i have to admit that while exhilarating
to see unfold so
so many details fell by the wayside for
me and in one way isayama was counting
on that unbeknownst to me and perhaps
many of you
dozens of clues had already been
advertised in order to prime us for the
reveals and surprises that will
eventually come to our attention down
the road however on
first viewing i found it to be somewhat
overwhelming at times
in this season dozens and dozens of new
characters are introduced
relationships are established and
political and military hierarchies are
presented to us
as well as a bizarre set of natural and
unnatural enemies that make the world of
attack on titan so interesting and
that's not even to make
mention of the anime eye catches that
you literally have to pause in order to
read
no one can read all of that in three
seconds i refuse to believe that
i'm i'm not bad at reading i promise
even today thinking back on all the
manga and anime i've watched
i've never in my leisure read a story
that's demanded so much from its
audience
in a way i think this is sort of like
mutual respect isyam is making the story
as rich and as dense as it needs to be
in order to tell this story faithfully
and
he trusts us to look and listen closely
with the added benefit of this being
when you sit back and decide you want to
watch the series again
it plays out almost like an entirely
different experience with the power of
hindsight you'll notice suspicious
conversations with annie and
even during the training corps errands
tighten healing on full display as the
steam freely floats from his head
after he takes that notorious fall with
his odm gear and all of this is only
possible to enjoy on a second viewing
which is
really where the phenomenal power of
attack on titan's writing can be
fully appreciated
levi is a phenomenal and traditional
shonen character after being introduced
to him and
his no-nonsense treatment during the
first half during this particular
section levi proves to be one of the
most important characters for us as an
audience to understand and connect with
in a story where bucking the tropes
became a regular occurrence having a
familiar and easier to understand
character like levi
felt a little bit like home to me and
while i wouldn't consider attacking
titan a show that has made me emotional
very often
the only character that's managed to
evoke that sort of connection from me
has been levi and they got an emotional
response from me once in the manga and
twice
in the anime through his character
little scenes like exploring how levi
would react towards his subordinates
death beds grabbing their hands or
retrieving something for them
after a hard fought battle these stand
in direct contrast with the nonchalant
tough guy persona he admonishes on the
surface
he's fun to watch for his titan slaying
abilities yes but
he's easier to cheer for because we
understand who he is
very easily
unfortunately isayama leverages that
fact too
in the story very quickly
in 2013 this captured my mind like few
other instances
i can think of having focused so
intently on the conflicts with the
perilous outside world
i never considered that there would be a
noteworthy threat
inside the walls mysteries are the bread
and butter of attack on titan and as
such these mysteries depend on the
story's ability to adhere to the rules
established within the world
they take place if you break existing
rules the audience feels cheated if you
didn't give the audience enough
information
they feel cheated if it doesn't make
sense in the end the audience
feels cheated and rightfully so in this
journey outside the walls irwin's planet
and his infiltration as the traitor
irwin's looking for
is handled to near perfection a sign of
a great reveal surprise or
mystery is seen in how our impression of
the characters involved either changes
or remains the same
if a surprise is handled poorly normally
it falls due to the incompetence of a
particular villain or
a flub by the writers looking to work
their way out of a hole that they've
created
in dragon ball super's goku black arc
tons of time is spent establishing how
time travel works
how the final battle is set up and how
it resolves
but in the end under its own logic
it still makes no sense leaving fans to
think that the characters are either
strange
foolish or nonsensical which is exactly
what attack on titan didn't
do here instead of providing the
necessary exposition to us
through dialogue we're instead shown how
this mystery works and where all the
pieces for this puzzle work because
everything in attack and titan that
isn't addressed works under real world
logic it makes sense as to why erwin
surprised aaron and asked if he knew who
the traitor was right after bean and
sonny were killed
because aaron couldn't have been
involved and was with hanji all night
talking about titan theory in addition
to that erwin releases potentially
sensitive information regarding aaron's
basement in chicago because he wants the
next expedition to involve this
traitor he suspects of being in their
midst and he feeds
everyone incorrect information regarding
the position of aaron all in an effort
to corner the female titan
in the forest as we watch this and as we
break this down even the entire
operation that erwin has concocted here
comes across as ingenious for him
despite his ultimate failure which came
about due to his lack of information
concerning the female titan's secret
abilities
and so in the end this scene serves to
successfully paint
irwin as the risk-taking strategic
genius he's supposed to be written to be
and we know this because it was
demonstrated not because we're told that
he's amazing
but because we see it for ourselves and
in addition to being shocked when i
watched this unfold my very first time
and my second time all the way through
it further served to divert my attention
inward and look at the rest of the cast
as possible threats
instead of exclusively looking outside
the walls for humanity's enemy and
speaking of humanity's enemies the fight
that takes place in the forest between
annie and aaron
somehow manages to make aaron look
monstrous terrifying and
awe-inspiring without him landing so
much as a single significant strike
just a whole bunch of misses grazes and
one admittedly heavy
but still blocked gut punch by annie and
again
even here in the moments where you would
think that things would be more
straightforward
attack on titan's foreshadowing
strengths are still being followed
through
running this is the moment aaron
hesitated and revealed his humanity and
it resulted in yet more loss and more
suffering for those he cared about
which i think is essential to keep in
mind for now furthermore and somewhat
interestingly almost
immediately after aaron suffers a
skull-shattering loss and kidnapping to
annie
in trying to take the initiative mikasa
ultimately highlights her flaw
cam and composed most of the time but as
soon as aaron's life is put at risk
she throws caution to the wind and
places her life on the line which again
something like this would be rewarded in
most shonen but not
attack on titan instead levi is there to
reprimand her and to further highlight
how unreasonable she's being
by this time levi had lost his entire
squad
on this mission and mikasa still had a
chance to save aaron despite this she
acted hastily and as a direct result of
that foolishness
injured humanity's best human weapon
levi
despite the promising results that
surfaced from a fantastic writing effort
on isiyama
in the end this outing highlighted how
woefully underprepared they all were for
the enemies beyond the walls
and all the more humanizing as after
their efforts they returned to insult
despair
and ridicule this entire sequence is
honestly phenomenal and gets better the
more you watch it the level of detail
and polish in the story is
frighteningly precise and the visuals
are stunning
assault on stohes one aspect of this
story that honestly struck me as an
improvement over the mangas was how it
slightly changed scenes included new
ones
and improved the flow of information to
the viewers such that the dramatic
moments became all the more
dramatic one very clear instance where i
leapt from my seat with joy was with
aaron being eaten in episode 5. by the
time that happened in the manga we
really hadn't spent all that much time
with aaron as a character and
it felt as though if that was it his
time spent was somewhat
pointless and thus the feeling that this
was really it for aaron felt less likely
as a result in the manga
there was no sort of closure apart from
the titan's mouth
however in the anime by the time aaron
meets his cruel fate he had become
something of an emotional leader within
his friend group and training corps in
other words he had impressed upon mikasa
and armin enough to make it a
possibility that he in fact
could have died and served a purpose
within the greater narrative which is i
think why this scene worked as well as
it did for so many as a fake out in the
anime and similarly regarding annie's
fight with aaron in stores
in the manga right before he transforms
in retaliation to annie aaron finds
himself unable to become a titan
but after some brief reflection and some
sobering words from mikusa he erupts
from beneath the floor and lands a
massive blow onto annie this is
perfectly fine but
i think the anime did it slightly better
while also playing into the themes and
future fate of aaron's character in
eye-opening ways
in the anime the flare for the dramatic
is emphasized even further he can't
transform for longer
we learn why and all the while he gets
trapped and impaled but needs some
rubble
due to this unforeseen hiccup the
military and his friends all have to
scramble for a contingency plan while he
has his reservations
all of these delays and grim
circumstances compound the initial
vision of that scene in the manga
and once aaron does transform we don't
see it
all we see are flashes of him running
past buildings windows shattering and
the fragile environment
of storehe's crumbled to the intensity
that he's charging with the first time
we see titan aaron
is
not only is this the first time we see
his titan form in this scene but it's
the first time he lands a meaningful
attack on annie
ever and all of these factors
culminating in this one scene
make it one of the most satisfying
punches in the season
furthermore this fight acts as a perfect
mirror image of their initial fight
during the forest battle wherein aaron
was very much unable to land a single
significant strike all the while annie
who was without the function of her arms
for much of the fight and the function
of her left eye
managed to use aaron's own attacks
against him but in the battle for stoics
aaron is very much a monster
seeking out his prey as annie runs for
her life interestingly and this is my
favorite observation regarding the final
fight scene with annie is that aaron's
momentary brief hesitation
right as he was about to consume annie
is the reason she was able to see
herself away in the safety of her titan
hardening armin even reiterates these
exact sentiments to him
after the battle during the closing
moments of the season 1 finale episode
implying that if aaron were to have
completely abandoned his humanity and
become nothing but a weapon fighting on
behalf of humanity
things could have turned out different
however the fact that annie was the
first to be reprimanded and outed as a
traitor
forced to seed herself away in a crystal
is just one of the many tragic and
horrific things that befall our main
cast
in this long and twisted story if the
conclusion of the battle of stowhees
district has taught us anything
is that we've taken the first step to
scratch the surface of this cruel
world's
mysteries
okay time out there's a titan behind the
wall okay so
not only are there enemies outside the
walls not only other enemies
inside the walls but there are enemies
also
inside the physical walls when i first
saw this this
was just the most impossible to
comprehend at the time plot swerve that
i not only didn't see coming but
once again convinced me that i still
know only a fraction of what this world
really has to offer
and the worst part is it went on hiatus
for four years
[Music]
for what i imagine are a large majority
of fans on titan's unique animation sits
as one of the defining and most beloved
aspects
of the show from the very first moments
of episode 1 audiences are greeted by an
astonishing piece of animation as the
survey core spiderman their way through
the forests to take down a titan there's
this sense of three-dimensionality to
the movement
and i'm not just talking about the gear
this scene is our first introduction to
arguably the most important name
attached to this franchise
and the man responsible for crafting
attack on titan's trademark action
arifumi imai whether you know his name
or not you will have almost certainly
fallen in love with
his work on the show as near enough
every iconic scene stems from his hands
even if you're watching this video with
zero exposure to attack on titan you
will have most likely seen his work
on the likes of one punch man borroto
vindan saga and countless other popular
shows
heck maybe you've seen his viral fan
animation of darth maul and obi-wan
because
somehow that's a thing and it's amazing
the man is honestly everywhere and it's
no surprise that he's become a bit of an
industry icon in recent years
however it's a very specific type of
animation that he brings to attack on
titan and it's that combination of 3d
backgrounds and 2d animation that
creates the wild camera work and
beyblade madness that defines the show
in the pre-production stage the action
sequences of attack on titan were
originally going to be entirely 3d
the show's 3d director shuhei yabuta
presented the team with a fully 3d
action scene that
seriously impressed the staff the series
director however
tetsuro araki someone who i'll be
touching on a little later
wasn't quite as impressed he wanted the
best of both worlds and
insisted on merging traditional
animation with the cg
action combining 2d in 3d is actually
not a new concept and its roots can be
traced
all the way back to 2003 in naruto's
original series a director by the name
of toshiyuki tsuru pioneered the concept
and its first major appearance can be
found in naruto's 48th episode in the
iconic battle between
gotta and rock lee over the years it's
become more and more prominent with it
even making an appearance in dragon
ball's revival movie battle of gods
despite however having a decade to rise
in prominence the workflow to achieve
this type of animation never really
found any sort of
logical consistency and that resulted in
some hilariously backward tedium you see
for a normal animated scene the typical
workflow is as follows an animator will
draw what is called a layout which is
essentially a very rough version of the
scene
used to convey to your director what
your intentions are and to show the
background team
what they need to paint after this you
animate it properly and then it's all
composed together for the final version
this is all done on pencil and paper up
until the coloring stage and that's the
norm in the industry contrary to popular
belief so
when am i popped up and started talking
about 3d backgrounds and wild camera
work the typical workflow it had to be
thrown out the window imai begins his
scenes with a very rough layout that
showcases how he'd like the animation to
play out this is then processed onto the
3d background team who will model this
scene and animate a camera fly through
for a maya to use to draw his animations
within this is where it gets kind of
hilarious though instead of
transitioning from pencil and paper to a
tablet and drawing over the 3d fly
through
the team would print out the individual
frames of the sequence
draw the animation over it and then scan
it all back in this went on
for months they kept using this
backwards workflow until an animator
called cinda yamaguchi who wasn't even
involved in this production
saw what they were doing and essentially
said this is the dumbest thing i've ever
seen in my life
why don't you just all start drawing
digitally and well
that's exactly what they did in my
transition over to using a tablet and
the workflow became
infinitely easier from the next season
onwards this bizarre and backwards
approach is honestly largely a
reflection of the studio behind the
series at this point
in time with studio is a subsidiary of
the very famous production ig
responsible for the likes of ghost in
the shell standalone complex and
psychopaths
it was founded by a man called george
walla in 2012 and
attack on titan was their very first
series despite the prestige of being
under a banner like ig port the higher
ops didn't really know what they were
doing or perhaps more critically
didn't really care now that's a bold
claim but it's not unsubstantiated
season 1 ran for 25 episodes but the
schedule and number of in-house staff
available
simply weren't enough to handle such an
action-heavy series alone
and unfortunately george wada didn't
care
going as far as to say in an interview
all the animators are sitting at their
desks all day and all night what saves
them from depression is one positive
comment from a fan
as though this all made it okay this
lack of preparation and disregard from
the higher ups put a real strain on the
show and
resulted in nine episodes being
outsourced as well as the need for a
recap episode halfway through
in particular the show's 13th episode
fell to pieces
with some cuts not being finished in
time resulting in some of the most
bizarre nonsensical sequences
coloring mistakes and questionable art
and while this issue persisted through
the series resulting in a huge number of
corrections for the blu-ray it really
came to a head in this episode and goes
a long way in explaining the need for a
recap immediately after however in spite
of these horrific circumstances behind
the scenes the show was a gigantic
success with its animation being at the
forefront of many fans praises
which begs the question how is that
possible then
well thankfully attack on titan is
blessed with a very strong core staff of
recurring animators
many of which there's just simply not
enough time to cover we've touched on
imai already but another big name is
asuyuki ibarra who much like imai works
with 3d camera work but
also has a real talent for character
acting the exceptionally exaggerated
melodramas seen here is another of these
defining titan traits
and that stems from the series director
tetsuro araki originally behind the
death note anime
fans of that show will be immediately
familiar with his ability to turn the
most mundane conversations into
big loud dramatic set pieces it doesn't
matter what's happening araki will find
a way to turn it into nail-biting
goodness and i think that distinctive
unabashed style of direction plays a
large part in why this series gripped so
many people back in the day i mean it's
kind of hard to tear your eyes away from
the screen
when you're being yelled at and his
style aside araki's long-standing
reputation within the industry meant he
had a
wealth of contacts to bring in as guest
animators to elevate the series visuals
episode 7 was outsourced to studio puro
which is a funny coincidence given
naruto's indirect influence on the
action this choice brought in the iconic
naoki kobayashi
animating aaron's transformation
likewise episode 7 brought in hironori
tanaka
an absolutely legendary animator whose
work you will have seen across
dozens of stunning shows and he animated
the devastating debut of aaron's titan
form
showing off his ability to animate
powerful humanistic movement and
delicate character
expression now of course a series cannot
survive on strong action scenes alone
if everything else looks potato so
thankfully for attack and titan it's
blessed with distinctive designs and a
strong animation director to keep the
show on
model while every anime needs a
character designer to adapt its manga
counterpart into a version that works
for animation isayama's artwork at this
point in the series was
not as refined as later in the series to
say the least usually featuring a lot of
hatching and really rough lines and thus
this would require a dramatic overhaul
to work for anime and that's where kyoji
asano comes in
as character designer he turned isa
yama's designs into polished model
sheets for animators to reference
in particular he used very thick
outlines to reflect the bold line work
of the manga
while simultaneously making alterations
to figure and form for more competent
anatomy and recognizability from
character to character
in the chief animation director role is
satoshi kadowaki a very talented
animator who used to work a kyoto
animation before moving to production ig
and eventually wit his job here is to
ensure adherence to the model sheets but
also to ensure expressions are solid and
animation moves the best
it can with these two together a solid
roster of regular animation directors at
their disposal and a powerful group of
recurring action animators attack on
titan's first season succeeded despite
its horrific circumstances behind the
scenes it's a triumph against the odds
and while it wasn't without its pitfalls
as we've addressed
it still managed to gain a reputation at
the time as one of the coolest looking
shows around with the polished blu-ray
version readily available these days
these pitfalls are largely relegated to
the distant memory of the broadcast
version now only found on streaming
sites like crunchyroll but
this is just season one and as the
series eventually pushed onwards into
new material in 2017
spectacular new visual and narrative
spectacle took
center stage once again the meteoric
rise of the series had been stunted by
the four year wait for season two
and so the question on everyone's minds
at the time was could attack on titan
capture that same lightning in a bottle
feeling in their sophomore
outing the answer no
they could only do better
season two of attack on titan took a
great series and
transformed it into one of the best i'd
ever experienced
bathed in failure mystery and tragedy
much like its predecessor however
this time there's a small glimmer of
hope on the horizon clash of the titans
clash of the titans is the longest story
arc we've yet covered in this review
spanning an entire season in almost five
volumes of its manga where the prior
season consisted of mainly easily
identified mini arc beginnings and
endings
clash of the titans continues on from
the events in the last but in doing so
covers one
massive incident that unfolds over the
course of many flashbacks and
earth-shattering revelations because my
adoration for the twists and surprises
of this series potentially border on the
insane
what i want to draw attention to and
praise first of all is that it gives a
much needed exploration into the many
side characters
surrounding our main trio of armin
mikusa and aaron
and how does it achieve this well
through intense conflict
while i didn't recognize or at the very
least didn't fully appreciate this on
first viewing what i later found
interesting about revisiting season
two's opening section is that a
considerable portion of the story takes
place
during the events that comprise the
assault on stowhes district covered in
season one which means all
of this is taking place while aaron is
dealing with annie and it's aftermath
who would have thought that this
wasn't the most shocking and awesome
thing happening at that time
and it's all made possible thanks to the
considerate and careful use of
flashbacks
by hajime isayama and i like this choice
for the same reason i'm keen on the use
of one piece's flashbacks and the
various means with which oda opts to
introduce us to and
come to better understand the
surrounding area for its viewers and
readers in any given location one of the
most challenging aspects when writing a
story is creating or manifesting a world
or atmosphere that feels real or potent
enough for you to identify with or
imagine yourself within if you're not
interested in the world the story is
taking place in then you may very well
be pushed away or left disinterested
making world building not only one of
the more difficult pieces of narration
to effectively employ
but also one of the most crucial
thankfully however isiama does a
phenomenal job in this department
and in this season i noticed just how
effective he can manage to be
when it comes to using the flashbacks as
a vehicle for this
it forced me to stop thinking of this
world as a set of scenes where nothing
is happening in the background and
instead
a deep and dynamic world full of
consequence and
danger around every corner if annie and
aaron were fighting then
where were the others what were they
doing
personally i'm someone that at all costs
tries to avoid spoilers and when i heard
that season 2 was coming i hid like
there was
no tomorrow from all of my social medias
for ages
and the result was the utter shock and
awe i felt when i first laid my eyes
on the beast type i didn't know mike as
a character all that well but as the
number two of the scouts behind
levi and skill getting to witness the
fate that befell him as the beast titan
interrogates and
ultimately disposes of him with truly
horrifying in all the best ways
furthermore after having outed annie as
a shifter i was fully anticipating the
next individuals that would come to the
surface
to be the armored and colossal titans
however instead isayama opted to show
this brand new hairy boy making me feel
all sorts of intimidated and confused at
the same time i wasn't sure as to what
was going on
and where this story was even going at
this point exactly
where he wanted me to be however this is
where things got a little more
complicated than they had been thus far
in the story
having to jump to and fro from point of
view character to point of view
character as they surveyed the
neighboring towns to help evacuate and
to try to locate the hole
all the while being sucked into
flashback after flashback
i think particularly in the anime which
added even more flashbacks than the
manga had already
served to kill the pacing for me in some
areas as well as sprinkle some confusion
in there on my first viewing despite
this i still think that what's added
offers more positive than negatives by a
wide margin
i'm not sure if i mentioned it yet but i
love sasha and
i love these chapters specifically once
again isa yama didn't explain to me why
she was worth admiring or showing
respect for
but instead demonstrated to us why she
is a phenomenally courageous and
interesting character all in her own
scene rich with backstory
immediate conflict and moments of true
altruistic heroism
now after season 1 i enjoyed sasha's
character i thought her comedic potato
bit that made everyone meme about it was
fun but the primary reason i found my
initial fondness for her was after what
she did to save samuel however with that
said she was still comfortably at that
point in the category of
needs more spotlight in order for me to
fully engage with her as a character
and boy in this season does she i love
this self-contained episode so much
i'm inclined to say that it's a dark
horse for best episode amidst this
supremely strong season's other
installments
in this one episode i went from feeling
lukewarm on sasha to her being one of my
favorite characters with a flashback
that explores how and why she came to
overcome her prejudices regarding
outsiders
figuring out where the importance of
community and kindness truly lies
and we see sasha change from someone who
would have once ran to protect herself
and contrast that with a sasha that we
now can see
makes use of the strengths that she has
to protect others that cannot protect
themselves
it's a powerful story with some horrific
and beautiful imagery it's emotional
it's tense and it's probably my favorite
episode from this season
but not my favorite piece of character
development
the beginning of this arc is quite
dynamic and somewhat frantic given that
the scouts are largely fractured into
smaller groups each with their own
individual missions concerning
evacuation and
checking out the wall for breaches top
to bottom some of the imagery
particularly in the dark of the night as
the scouts worry about what might be
lurking out there and the dark of the
dingy castle they eventually find
themselves in
all of this both in the manga and the
anime serves to really capture
the horror aspect of the series and it's
in these moments of panic we finally get
to explore a character that up until
this point
hadn't even received a name in the manga
yet and that person
is yamir once again i have to admit that
when i first delve into season two
the individual's smaller scope character
flashback stuff
left me somewhat unsatisfied and to tell
you the truth if you had asked me a few
years ago
after my first viewing which i preferred
season one or two
i think i might have said season one
quite confidently however now
after having revisited it and after
having taken a closer look at how it
works
i adore this dynamic ymir is shown to
have with historia who up until this
point i had only ever really known as
the nervous girl that gave sasha help
during training
that one time however what's interesting
about them isn't necessarily their
communication or what their
personalities are that made their
dynamic so fruitful within the story for
me it's instead how their characters
clash
and inform the act they're each
undergoing separately in other words
it makes sense why amir is the way that
she is and thus makes sense why she is
drawn to historia
and through a very eye-opening flashback
we see that the sweet girl of historia
is actually willing to kill herself and
by extension daz
just to appear like a good person to the
others before she dies
and on the other side of the coin
historia eventually recognizes the
weakness in a mirror that she didn't
think that she has
neither of them are living for
themselves however their respective
dynamics and challenges push each other
to become
more well-rounded and secure characters
upon second and third viewings i
enjoyed their portion of the story so so
much
that i'd even posit that there's a
strong argument to be made that their
journey and story in this season
is easily the most underappreciated
component of it taking two characters
one of which i hadn't even heard of and
another that i had almost totally
forgotten about
managing to explore their lives and
backstory so brilliantly that i ended up
not only caring about them but also
found it to be
immeasurably fascinating when breaking
it all down upon my revisit
and also this was awesome now this is a
small and
somewhat surface level observation but
this instance among many others helped
me appreciate that this season gave me
much more than i was anticipating even
on my first
go-around the series had already hooked
me with its premise and its existing
titan threat alone but the fact that
this continued to drip feed
more and more information leading to
different and newer titan shifters being
revealed felt exhilarating to sit and
gawk at in amazement the beast titan and
now this new gremlin-like titan that
emir is brandishing to defend the castle
with
gave me more questions than i ever could
have dreamt of particularly after reiner
confronts amir as she reads some
supplies she finds in the castle
brandishing a language those within the
walls apparently
shouldn't be familiar with at that point
i'm like what does that even mean
who are these people where did these
suppliers come from
when can they transform why do they all
look different why do some of them want
to take out humanity within the walls
and why do
others defend them and what would have
happened if amir
wasn't there to have made the save that
day i'm sorry in advance for my gushing
regarding this upcoming section but this
literally brought attack on titan from a
9 out of 10 to a 10 out of 10 for me and
look listen
i adore one piece but it wasn't my first
love attacking titan gave me that big
heavy foreshadowing surprise first and
for that reason it would always hold a
special place in my heart so
get this right i adore this scene more
than i thought was humanly possible for
a man to love flashing colors on a
digital screen
i was unreasonably excited holy [ __ ]
oh my god okay it's happening oh man
but that came with problems not with the
execution of the story those are
okay no we don't talk about improving
this scene it's perfect
the problems i had came about because
season two took so long to come out
instead of watching this scene with my
friends and family that i had before
i was watching it alone and i had
no one to talk about this
earth-shattering revelation with
in a way despite my forever alone set of
circumstances at the time
this yielded a massive benefit in that
it forced me to reconvince my family and
friends to cut the series again
which meant that i too would watch along
with them and that's when i realized
that to fully appreciate this series
it needs to be consumed once blind and
then re-watched as you're armed with all
the greater understanding the plot has
provided you with
never in all of my life up until that
point had i been as blown away by a
story
this show that i had been such a massive
fan of for five years at that point
demonstrated to me that not only was it
brilliant but it was so
in ways i never once noticed
what these unveiling or mask off moments
for the characters of attack on titan
are among the most
expertly and carefully handled that i've
come across
certainly the most numerous and isayama
achieves this by
perfectly managing what the audience is
explicitly told
and implicitly told in short explicitly
informing your audience of a given plot
point is
exposition this can be seen through
annie outing herself as the female titan
through aaron popping out of his titan's
nape or levi showing us that he's a
great soldier these are all pieces of
information that explicitly inform us
through no uncertain terms
that annie is the female titan aaron is
also a titan shifter
and levi is a badass but this isn't what
impressed me
tons of stories have these climactic
moments of revelation but what makes
them work or
brilliant however is how they are
foreshadowed through
implicit information being strategically
given to us
throughout the story to put it simply
implicit pieces of info
are the uncertain but curious behaviors
or choices made by certain characters or
components within your story
that if you had been paying attention or
suspicious could very easily have
pointed you in the direction of their
true intention
and it's through this analysis of when
and how this use of implicit
communication we begin to understand
the scope of the story and the benefits
an author like isayama can enjoy
when he understands how the story is
going to end from day
one this is why attacking titan is a
show worth watching from the start a
second time at the least it's an
entirely different experience
running back through the story with my
friends and family now armed with an
understanding of who was who
and where the story was going my mind
was free to pay attention to details
outside of the plot i was left utterly
speechless
and in awe of the sheer number of
implicit hints i missed out on
whether it be keith shadis waltzing
right past all of the titan shifters on
induction day
their curious placement in the second op
how suddenly interested reiner was in
aaron's titan before we knew it was
aaron how annie found out where aaron
was in the scouting formation in the end
all of the sketchy hint-filled
conversations they have and can we talk
about the cans again
all those are only a small few of the
dozens of hints we were given concerning
the true nature of reiner
bertolt and annie however for many
reiner and berthold's ultimate reveal as
the culprits behind shingencine's fall
stand as some of the most unique and
shocking the series has to offer
i spoke about the director of this
series briefly before but his flair for
the germanic really helped to elevate
for comparison's sake and his mask off
moment and soon to follow transformation
thereafter in season one it's cinematic
and it's a thunderous moment for what
might be annie's
biggest moment in the series however
with regards to reiner and bertolt
this reveal broke my brain and i think
it did so for two very
important and clearly identifiable
reasons the most obvious identifier
within this revelation has to be how
understated it is when said alongside
other important moments in the series
even other big revelations like
annie's the difference in staging is
clear for all to see
it's clear the director of this episode
wants there to be a chance
that you could have missed this moment
entirely it's not the focus of the scene
and even in the manga isayama has reiner
reveal
all of this information to aaron in the
background with the focus being on other
characters
this serves to put us as audience
members into the minds of the scouts
much like many of them
we did not see this being the time or
place for such a reveal and certainly
not in such a straightforward manner
which ultimately serves to create the
second and most powerful component that
makes this scene work like it did
and that's contrast due to the low-key
nature of the unveiling once things
start to kick off with mikasa almost
killing them both their ultimate
transformations are made to feel all the
more monumental
and titanic thanks to this very
understated build up
and to paint a picture for you i was off
my seat
dancing and cheering as aaron lamented
the loss of his friends
and shifted into a savage anger-filled
titan
lunging forward with intent to kill
worth mentioning at this point also is
that there's a marked improvement in
this section's manga material compared
to the earlier volumes where the artwork
was to isiyama's own estimations
memorably bad in these sequences however
the panels are emphatic
and thoughtfully composed so much so
that during my research for this video i
for the first time
in my research got sucked into reading
further than i needed to on more than
one occasion
but unfortunately this improvement in
the manga comes at the cost of the
anime's adaptation
while i think 3d can be used well to
complement 2d animation in a variety of
interesting ways if handled correctly
i do not think that what season two and
even what later on in the series
demonstrates can be described as
anything other than
immensely distracting and that's me
being charitable
made all the more evident as it stands
in direct contrast with one of the most
well animated fight sequences this
series has to offer
reiner versus erick
[Music]
there's a great story being told here of
how aaron is forced to employ restrained
strategy and patience to contend with
the stronger and more durable armored
type all the while the scouts have to
figure out
burn burn to the ground yeah i don't
think i've been more amped up for a
fight than i was for aaron vs reiner and
i certainly have never seen a fight like
this attempted in an anime before
and while in recent years i have brought
in my horizons in that regard
i have yet to see a fight handle mixed
martial arts better and more
impressively
than this did like today i watched two
mma guys break down this very fight
and it was awesome did you know that
this takedown that aaron does was called
an osotogaddi well i do now and it's
thanks to these guys
and attack on titan i guess takedowns
triangle chokes armbars guillotines and
variations on takedown defense
this fight takes all the components of a
fight that more casual observers might
describe as boring in mma and throughout
this fight
educates a general audience on the
strategy utility and the entertainment
value
found within a fight like this serving
not only to make a fantastic fight but
offer it a distinct and unique flavor in
a series that up until this point
had fights which were composed largely
of kicking punching
and missing punching
[Music]
within a story like this there's always
something in the future for us as an
audience to hang on for isayama will
always have a series of medium and short
term mysteries to drag us along with
like
will they retrieve aaron from the
warriors why are they there and who's
the beast titan despite all of these at
some point or another being answered
there is always a long-term question
hanging in the air
for us too while this section is largely
composed of action
intense character exchanges massive set
pieces and one
massive emotional question mark at the
end what managed to captivate me during
this dynamic pursuit was less so the
action and more so how nuanced and
believable
all of the main players behaved take
amir for example
thanks to the prior flashbacks we
understand where her allegiances lie
and thus in talking to reiner she starts
working with them because she believes
that what historia currently has
is unsustainable that she doesn't have a
future within these walls so
not only is this a believable motivation
that informs the crucial decision she
ultimately makes
but it also helps to paint a grim
picture for where reiner and bertholdt
are from
originally there's also this tremendous
character moment for irwin who
while leading his squad gets taken by a
titan only two
okay look i know this is a fictional
world but good god almighty would i
follow that man through the gates of
hell
another example of nuance and meaning
found in this sequence has to be
berthold's conflicted
and guilt-ridden mindset throughout here
yes we do in fact during this season to
varying degrees
both reiner and berthold have
demonstrated that there's a possibility
that there's possibly
a likable person beneath the surface
despite the atrocities they've committed
making the emotional torment and
physical pain these two undergo
in the chase all the more
thought-provoking distracting us from
[Music]
holy [ __ ] erwin you absolute
monster down an arm and he still secures
the target
honestly this entire chase sequence had
me on the edge of my seat from its
hopeful beginnings to its almost
hopeless end after having exhausted some
tremendous strategies from armin and
heroin
some incredible feats by mikasa and
securing aaron even
once again they are forced to deal with
the harsh reality of this world
and oddly this portion of the conclusion
felt somewhat final and
peaceful to me i'm not really sure if
i'm alone in thinking or feeling this
but my first go through this series
this was the one and only erin yeager
moment
to invoke some sort of emotional
response from me
as i mentioned prior in this review i
believe in and respect the idea
and utility of erin yeager's character
within this series
i don't think it would work without him
he's a fundamental component to how this
story functions
but he's not the most relatable his
desire to achieve his goals borders on
the psychotic much of the time and his
facial expressions and threats
particularly during the treetop sequence
remind me more of norman bates from
1960s psycho than a typical shonen
protagonist
but this scene it hit me differently
maybe it's the staging maybe it's
hannah's courageous attempt to overcome
his guilt and save the two kids
maybe it's mikasa thanking aaron for
being in her life and saving her
or maybe it's the very human moment we
share with aaron as he crumbles the
floor in tears
faced with the reality that once again
despite the new powers
despite all everyone has done despite
all that he has done
he is still a slave to the circumstances
he finds himself in
powerless helpless and defenseless
yet in the face of this he stands up
comforts mikasa and faces certain death
unflinchingly without fear this got me
knowing full well that he is going to
his death aaron remains true to himself
and his convictions proving to us that
while he might be a lot at times
he believes everything he says and is
willing to die
[Music]
okay wait what was that what happened
and why is aaron suddenly a titan bender
leave it to attack on titan to answer a
ton of questions in the single season
only to leave us with way more god i
love
this moment and what's more is this
moment on top of giving the scouts an
opening for them to escape it also gives
a mere reason to leave historia with the
scouts
because aaron proved in this moment that
those living within the walls might
actually have a future
behind the scenes season two despite the
second season being greenlit immediately
following season one's broadcast
and huge success it took four years for
it to finally hit the air
now of course the show wasn't in
production during these four years at
least not in the sense of things being
storyboarded or animated the show truly
didn't begin being made until
late 2016 so i think it's important to
talk about
why it took so long to pick back up
contrary to popular belief the gap
didn't purely exist to create a buffer
between the anime and manga
all of season 2's narrative content was
entirely finished within the manga by
the time the first season of the anime
had finished airing the primary reason
was more so to do with
structure while the arc featured in
season 2 is very action-packed filled
with reveals and intense set pieces
what follows is a low-key politically
driven arc an arc that isayama wasn't
particularly happy with and one fans
weren't hugely engaging with at the time
either
with the staff to create another 26
episode season it would have started
with a bang yes
and then peter out into this more
subdued arc thereafter
as i'm sure you can imagine and as the
staff realized
that didn't make for a very gripping
finale and the solution was to split the
sequel into what we have today an
action-packed second season
followed by a political arc to kickstart
a third season a year later leading into
the climactic
second half of this season that would
inevitably stick in audiences minds
due to the sheer number of narrative
beats while news of the second season
would only be 12 episodes after many
years of waiting angered fans
it ultimately turned out to be a
blessing in disguise the production was
significantly stronger this time around
with every single episode this time
being created
in-house while the show began on april
1st 2017
the staff had already finished episode 1
in its entirety by the end of 2016 with
episode 2 already hitting the animation
phase in january of 2017.
it's far from perfect but a far far cry
from the state of season one and with
the popularity of that first season
this also meant many freelancers were
itching to join the team which went a
long way in boosting the overall quality
of this second outing i mean the famous
aaron vs reiner fight brought in some
super stars such as toshiyuki sato naoki
oshibe and itsuki tsuchigami
phenomenally talented animators who many
of you will undoubtedly know from the
wonderfully animated mob
psycho 100. of course the old superstar
team of ibisu ibarra and imai
who carried season 1's action make their
return here in an even bigger way also
actively looking to one-up their
previous efforts taking full advantage
of the show's
new forgiving schedule and this roster
of incredible action animators really
can't be overstated but
the improvements don't simply exist
within the action space
while season 1's dialogue scenes largely
consisted of stills with flapping mouths
season 2 managed to introduce legitimate
character acting animation with young
new talents like kana ito making
characters actually feel alive during
moments of downtime however perhaps the
most dramatic overhaul within this
season comes in the form of wit studio's
newfound
makeup team between season one and two
of attack on titan director tetsuro
araki and much of the titan team had
created cabanari of the iron fortress
where this new technique was established
it involves a team of digital artists
going over
shots and painting in extra detail
particularly in the hair and eyes
while its use on kevin airy was fairly
haphazard often popping up sporadically
with little rhyme or reason
its presence in attack on titan's second
season functioned largely the same as
harmony cells did in old anime to create
dissonance in aid
of impact for instance the first
appearance of the beast titan connie
laying eyes on his family or historia
and emir's emotional interaction
all of these scenes stand out very
literally from the rest of the series
visuals add so much to the weight of
these occasions
people will always notice when
something's different and titan season 2
takes advantage of this whenever it can
unfortunately
with the many improvements season 2
brings there are some major caveats that
are important to acknowledge also
and one of them i mentioned earlier the
3d colossal titan the team at madbox are
responsible for the series cg and
unfortunately the work on display here
is less than great i think it's
important to understand why this titan
is cg however
and the answer is probably not all too
surprising it's entirely to do with time
in season one this titan was nothing but
a static head
and any action around it was minimal
coming into season two onwards however
there are entire action sequences built
around this titan with complex rotations
and camera movement the issue is
the colossal titan's design is just as
complicated as any
insanely detailed mech is it is covered
in hundreds of tiny lines detailing the
musculature
and full of segments just drawing one
frame of this character is difficult
enough but
once you introduce any sort of movement
let alone rotations
you're then looking at hundreds of
sheets that all need to be perfectly
detailed
and consistent in form from frame to
frame not only is this astonishingly
difficult to pull off but
that is months upon months of work that
no tv production is ever going to
achieve without destroying itself
using cg is not a sin anyone remotely
familiar with trigger or euphonible's
efforts will know this fact perfectly
well
take this scene from killer kills first
episode for example
everything here is cg and yet you'd
barely be able to tell due to the way
the texture work is perfectly matched to
the rest of the scene
and traditional animation timing and
techniques have been employed such as
smears
unfortunately the cg in the wit studio
era of attack on titan makes no such
effort to blend using textures that
don't look remotely like the rest of the
series
and linear animation timing that
ultimately looks more like a low frame
rate video game than the traditional
frame modulation you see in 2d animation
it may allow for some spectacular
sequences but
it sure comes at the cost of seamless
integration the second caveat of this
season
is also time related despite the
significant improvements found in season
2 schedule the pressures of the
production did
ultimately catch up to the team
resulting in dozens of animation
directors per episode struggling to hold
things together
the biggest example of these struggles
are most apparent in episode 11 where
any sort of complex piece of animation
involving multiple characters
were relegated to shaking stills nice
looking stills but still is all the same
despite my talking about these caveats
in quite a bit of detail
they're incredibly minor in the grand
scheme of things and ultimately as of
this video
season 2 remains the strongest
production the titan series has ever
seen
some people might not even be aware that
episode 10 could be called the studio
ghibli episode of the series
with ex-ghibli staff members kenji imura
and masayuki miyagi
directing and boarding respectively and
while the episode has little to write
home about in terms of wild animation
the way it's storyboarded and
particularly the use of lighting is
absolutely unrivaled it feels distinctly
different from any other
titan episode and when you look at the
minds behind it it's
easy to see why araki also brought in
his friend takayuki hirao from studio
uforable best known for directing the
fifth garden of sinner's film for the
iconic seventh episode of the season
delivering on some of the season's most
impactful moments
ultimately season two was the perfect
storm it managed to iterate on
and perfect the concepts found in the
first season while offering up
interesting new ideas
and executing them with newfound finesse
thanks to an improved schedule
to this day it is still the shining
beacon of the franchise now 70 plus
episodes deep and although this
consistent level of polish across the
board won't be found again
the animation peaks don't stop here
season 3 may contain the lowest of lows
but it also contains some of the most
extravagant
ambitious and unforgettable of highs
and at this poll i took on twitter
asking all of you which your favorite
seasons were is
any indication i'd say this second half
is something special
[Music]
the uprising arc alright this is going
to be a tough one to fully break down so
wish me luck of all the arcs i've
discussed aside from this
also being quite long the differences
between the manga and the anime are
substantial however nothing that changes
too much regarding the plot
in short the anime tends to extend
rearrange or embellish
action sequences like kenny chasing levi
in favor of shortening or removing
certain dialogue scenes i think looking
at this critically it's important to
recognize the pitfalls an adaptation
must try to avoid when it's creating its
anime counterpart and so i'd imagine
many of the decisions made for season 3
part 1 came about
due to pacing concerns and this arc
boasts a really cool idea
opting to momentarily turn our attention
away from the titan threat outside
the walls and to instead focus on the
corruption of the world within them
dealing with political unrest
boatloads of eye-opening exposition that
unearths a massive conspiracy and
some of the most disgusting visuals this
property has yet offered up to us
[Music]
for the most part i thought a lot of the
changes here were welcomed
particularly when we consider the
different pacing requirements an anime
might have when compared to a manga take
episode 1 for example it covers chapters
51 52 53 54 and 57
primarily culminating on this moment the
most notable exemptions from these
chapters are the experiments on eren's
titan and historia's backstory on the
farm and while these aren't present
in this section anymore they are later
on in the season instead though i will
say that while we do get to see the
aftermath of these titan experiments in
the anime
the manga went into much more detail
dedicating almost an entire chapter to
these experiments alone
gleaning lots of extra interesting
pieces of information not essential
information but
interesting nonetheless overall i can
appreciate and understand the necessity
for these changes
it's important for a story to feel like
it's moving forward and choosing to end
this episode on a sudden shocking murder
kickstarting a chase scene with levi
is a much more favorable cliffhanger
than some expository dialogue exchange
that this section is filled with however
you might have also noticed that two
chapters were missing from that
aforementioned list of covered chapters
in this first episode those being
chapters 55 and 56
this material while not present in the
same order as a manga
is presented in later anime episodes and
are either significantly less detailed
or have been entirely changed chapter 55
is almost entirely the torture scene
with levi hanji and the military police
soldier
i think this version from the anime only
served to remove a lot of the gore
with all the necessary details still
remaining and so therefore i think this
is a welcome change however in saying
that
it's not all great changes one such
removed exchange i otherwise really
appreciated came from a scene wherein
levi reveals to everyone that historia
is to be made queen if their coup of the
government is to be successful here i
think something is lost or at the very
least made much less interesting
and less rich due to this creative
decision initially historia resists and
is overcome by the responsibility
resulting in
levi grabbing her by the scruff of her
neck willingly and happily playing the
bad guy
his speech in this scene is great and it
paints him as a tough but fair person
that is willing to walk the walk and
talk the talk however the best aspect to
be gleaned from this scene is a
conversation that is led by mikasa after
the fact when people start questioning
or
doubting levi in that moment she backs
up her captain
and acts as the soldier she needs to be
couple this with her asking about the
condition of levi's ankle later on on
the rooftop and you've got a clearly
shown progression of her character after
implementing the lesson she learned
that day in the force against the female
titan it's a subtle but great moment and
unfortunately it's left out of the anime
completely making mikusaf feel more
lifeless as a result which
is a shame because all she seems to be
known for in the anime is
loving eren which is an important part
of her character but
not the only part overall the changes
made to the existing chapters revolved
largely around streamlining
conversations and combining separate
scouting missions into one more focused
operation that helped to tie everything
together in a much more
straightforward and believable way at
the end of season 2's material i
mentioned a twitter poll i took
that pointed to season 3 being the most
liked season of them all
though i am certain had season 3 only
being this first
half concerning the political uprising
the poll would most definitely have
turned out very different
and that's not to say that i thought
that this section of the story was bad
or that it wasn't a great idea
far from it but i do however think that
when said alongside
all the other parts of the story it
stands out as possibly the slowest and
least interesting portion for some
and while i can only speak to my own
experience i would wager that it is
largely due to the lacking development
and attention given to
the aristocratic class and military
police throughout this story up until
now that play such a large role in this
section while they have been present
here and there
those moments have always been fleeting
and infrequent at best the military coup
that takes place in this section is
vital for making later more interesting
storylines work
it's a necessary plot point in the story
but for a great deal of time during it
while there were some great ideas and
some versions to successfully pull off
the coup
i was still waiting for these scenes to
pass on by so that we could focus on the
rod reese family plot thread which i
found to be far more engaging due to its
focus on primary characters
and the truth of the world and so while
i didn't dislike the military coup
section i did think it was the weakest
part of the story due to my lack of
emotional connection to many of the key
characters involved
though that's not to say that all of
these interactions are less interesting
encounters like jean's hesitation to
take out members of the military police
served as a key moment for his character
and his mission to become a better
leader
also there's this really nice scene in
the woods with jon 2 and i think without
getting too
lost in the weeds here my main takeaway
has been that while the manga has more
details and a few
interesting and somewhat important
instances that the anime doesn't have
it's also a version of the story that
left a large portion of the reader base
less
interested and it's a key part of the
story which is himself wasn't
particularly happy with either leading
to his direct involvement with season
three's anime adaptation but thankfully
once the monarchy is taken down and the
military gains control over the
government
the plot really starts to get moving and
the tension rises
dramatically the time taken to set up
the chess board the way that they wanted
to has taken time yes
and to some people may have been
somewhat tedious but thanks to it being
handled the right way
none of the characters current
motivations or placements feel forced or
contrived and we can all now focus not
on separate splintered points of
interest but instead
one major operation the rescuing of
aaron and historia
from rod reese let's back up for a
second or two here
this for me was always the main point of
interest in this story the truth behind
the royal family and the coordinate
power of the titans and
interestingly now looking back on this
portion of the series the character that
holds this entire season together is
kenny ackerman if you look back through
the story at other characters that
occupy a temporary role in this story
like levi squad marco or
even hannes these are all characters
that are brought in to fulfill a minor
narrative requirement be it functional
or motivational and once they fulfill
that purpose
they then exit stage left heck annie can
fall into that category too she told the
story that was required offer and now
she's a crystal girl but my point is
this isn't some new idea in storytelling
and sometimes it can be great like
hannah's emotionally driven multi-arc
development where he contributes to the
message and purpose of the arc before
saying goodbye but
it can also feel a little forced i'm not
sure how i felt about this but while i
was watching season one on my first go
around
while i enjoyed levi's squad and found
their personalities endearing
to me they were very obviously redcoats
there to serve the purpose of a somewhat
established character's death in the
series
this i didn't personally get a lot out
of but it by no means hindered my
ability to enjoy the season
kenny on the other hand is a character
that unlike levi's squad plays a pivotal
role in telling this story
so much so i can't even begin to
understand how it would possibly be told
without him
which is exactly why i think he was
created in the first place and once the
arc
ends so does kenny on one hand i can
appreciate his connection to levi's past
making him a character directly linked
to a fan favorite
and i also found his connection to the
royal family filled with plenty of
interesting interactions like their
first meeting but i can't help but feel
indifferent to him as a character
i can understand his personality fine
and i can appreciate his point of view
and i found it to be exciting at times
also
but at the end of the day i couldn't
shake the feeling that
he wasn't that important to the plot of
the greater series
and he wasn't in a sense prior to season
3 part 1 he doesn't exist and
isn't mentioned again until season 4's
annie reiner and berthold flashback
material as a cameo
because of this despite isayama's best
efforts to build up a family legacy
around the ackermann name
with his connections to the reese family
and secrets of the world kenny at the
end of the day
seemed to me like a fleshed out plot
device or at the very least like he
wasn't part of isiah's vision for the
series from the beginning and instead
something he concocted later on this is
all to say that i do enjoy him
and his part of the story insofar as he
contributed interesting opportunities
for exposition
and to further the plot but as a
character however i wasn't particularly
engaged by him i do however feel like i
am somewhat alone in feeling this way
and kenny seems to be something of a fan
favorite amongst the fan base sporting a
terrific design
and driving the story in this section
like no other this aspect of the story
was honestly my favorite part of this
section
even taking giant blob titan rhys into
account the sense of scope and scale
these revelations offer the series made
my
head spin all those visions aaron's been
having well they're all thanks to this
person the passive king behind the walls
something that really blew my mind while
i was watching this was this tiny but
really cool piece of continuity if we go
back to around the first time aaron
transformed it's clear to see that aaron
even back then
was utilizing memories of his father
watching frida reese transform before he
inevitably killed them
which all informed his very first
transformation frida transformed the
very same way and aaron even back then
was seeing flashes of greece's final
moments too it's not given much
attention at all but
i appreciate it nevertheless
consistencies shown over the course of a
long running series are what gets me to
write multiple hour video essays like
these
of all the characters i've discussed
thus far concerning this season
specifically historia
unfortunately is one of those characters
that ended up losing more than her fair
share in the aforementioned cut material
all in the name of pacing to be clear
though i still love her inclusion in the
anime i found what part she did play to
be both emotional and
compelling climaxing on that amazing
moment where she denies everything she
thought she wanted her entire life in
favor of staying true to the person
emir wanted her to be and who she
herself wants herself to be
it's a powerful and inspiring moment
sharpened by the phenomenal musical
track
unique to this moment that i may or may
not have listened to hundreds of times
because of this very scene whether it be
the outburst learning that they won't be
going after amir
her conversation with erin her
reluctance and ultimate confrontation
with levi concerning her becoming queen
all the way to her eventual acceptance
all of these moments in one form or
another were either caught entirely or
altered considerably and not to
historia's benefit i think
even so this scene in the crystal cave
is still a powerful one
where two central characters learn of
their past serving to mentally
crush aaron and empower historia both
for totally understandable and
satisfying reasons and even though i did
enjoy what the anime produced
maybe even more than the manga i can't
help but feel i cared so much more about
the historia character in the manga
thanks specifically to the presence of
key character moments
many of which i mentioned were cut still
i felt that largely attack on titan
stuck the landing and
thanks to the wealth of exposition and
plot after happening in this season so
far
the story is now primed to get back to
what they do best
deal with crazy as hell's set pieces
holy [ __ ]
what the hell is that oh my god
orvo district section of the story is
honestly quite short and in my view was
there
to act as a coronation of sorts for
historia primarily all the while showing
off how efficient the scouts
and aaron can be when they work together
free from the watchful corrupt eyes of
the capital monarchy
and this has some of the most memorable
set pieces in the series i think
rodriguez's desperate transformation
into the goopy blobby island-sized titan
dragging his face across the land only
to reveal that he
yeah he doesn't have a face it's gross
it's graphic
it's awesome and it's damn memorable and
looking back over the course of this
section of the story i
have to say that i admire its dedication
to the political thriller it was aiming
for its perseverance in adapting an
altered version of it for the anime and
it's incredibly cathartic finally
getting to see and expose the injustices
and corruption of the world government
fall resulting in the scouts finally
being treated as the heroes they deserve
to be
and seen as aaron's reaction of the
cheers and adulation of the crowd paint
him as someone that while he never
anticipated or did
what he did for the cheers he most
certainly appreciates them
for he knows how treacherous the next
mission is going to be because if you
thought this uprising portion was why
everyone loved this arc you'd be
sorely mistaken for what you've just
seen while great
has simply been the build up or prelude
to what i consider to be
the best anime viewing experience of my
life
return to shigen china this is the ark
that made attack on titan
my favorite story never and i mean
never has a story so potently and
perfectly captured
my imagination the way this has
completely satisfying my more analytical
side by capitalizing brilliantly on
previously established content
while also educating me on things i
never understood before
in other words this was the arc that
inspired me to one day
write this video and yes it is that damn
good
it has everything and i mean that action
the best in the series so far
high stakes highest so far in the series
character progression like we've never
seen before and that's not even to draw
attention to the world building and lore
finally revealed in this season and so i
guess what i'm trying to say is
if this act were a person i would have
already introduced them to my parents
gotten married and had perfectly written
children with them there's this
feeling that we've truly come full
circle and transformed alongside these
characters we've begun to uncover the
truths of the world and boy are we in
much more of a dominant position
as a result while watching this i had
this feeling of euphoria come over me as
the scout so effortlessly plugged up the
hole in wall maria
something that was once such an ordeal
in trust now is a non-issue
this is very literally the culmination
of everything we've gone through so
far aaron is now fully in control of his
titan the military are now in full
control of their own efforts and they
can utilize
titan hardening however we are still
encroaching onto enemy territory and
believe me when i say that i felt that
with each
passing step into this familiar location
made possible thanks to the coffee
grinder and limited remains armin finds
of a camp
despite us returning to the place where
it all began attack on titan managed to
make this once familiar
and in some ways nostalgic location feel
more alien
and more dangerous than anywhere else
we've come across in the story
making for strange but welcomed feelings
of unease brewing in my mind
and as armin's concerns shift from
suspicion to near certainty the tension
rises gradually this is a cam before a
storm
and what a storm
this scene made me sweat and to this day
a show has never made me do that before
being so close to the scout's point of
view as they slowly come to realize just
how outmatched they may very well be
serves to excite us yes but it also
further places us in the corner of the
characters we relate to the most the
scouts that are now cornered and
fighting for their lives
for me the highlight and what sticks out
of my mind from this opening
establishment has to be the sudden
surprise look that falls across
erwin's normally relaxed face it's one
of the only times we actually get to see
erwin shocked and while brief
it was enough to send shivers down
through my spine in addition to that i
love the point of view we get to see all
this from because light travels faster
than sound when the titans appear
we as an audience get to see what's
happening on the ground below before
erwin hears it
it's a small detail but it goes to show
how much effort was put into these
scenes establishing the stakes the
setting and positioning the upcoming
conflict to be the greatest and most
important fight
in the history of this show as erwin
bellows to his shaking troops were both
hoping for the same thing
to settle it here once and for all
humanity or titans
which side will live which side will
perish
i've sat her in my seat for five minutes
trying to collect my thoughts and
feelings on this scene and put it into
words but the level of excitement i felt
that day while watching this i sincerely
cannot effectively convey
with the scouts now forced to split up
against seemingly insurmountable odds it
was
at this point i knew i was getting ready
to witness something truly special and
before i get into the specifics like i
know all of you want me to
i want to first draw attention to what i
think makes this fight work so
effortlessly and therefore effectively
in a nutshell isayama has managed our
knowledge of this series such that we
understand
exactly the right amount to enjoy this
situation to the utmost
while also withholding certain pieces of
information to help us enjoy it even
more like the beast titan being able to
summon titans is a great uno reverse to
surprise us with and create
tension we know what characters are and
are not capable of we know that they
only have one way of getting horses over
the walls and we came to learn that
earlier in the story we know what the
topographical nature of sheik and sheena
is and how the walls are built around it
essentially thanks to the time and
energy spent expanding upon this world
and its characters
isayama is now free to focus exclusively
on setting the stakes and positioning
his individuals according to where he
thinks makes the best
fight we have two teams one is in
shingenshina and the other is trapped
outside
both are fighting for their lives and
will most likely
die and oop there they go and okay so
that's happening on one side of the wall
and what about the other side
if you cast your minds back to any of
your favorite fights from fiction they
almost
always follow a somewhat similar
structure and one of the most crucial
points of that structure that makes any
fights ending feel massive
is a low point before the finish goku vs
frieza effectively achieved this by
making frieza more monstrous than goku
ever could have imagined jojo's bizarre
adventure utilizes this all the time but
my favorite occurs during dio versus
jodorow where judo almost dies trying to
stop dio and even in more
modern western media like the avengers
films 1-4
they all made full use of this technique
in all of their final battles and so
in other words the more cornered or
close to the feet you can get your hero
team to be
the better and with erwin's side in the
panic and air inside
after almost all being completely blown
to pieces thanks to berthold's
transformation with the world being as
cruel as it is and with there being no
obvious way forward to victory as an
audience member i was sitting there in
despair alongside these characters and
this is where the key mechanical
differences between attack on titan and
dragon ball
surface where dragon ball relied on what
eventually became a shonen trope in goku
getting angry
and achieving a new power-up to overcome
frieza attack on titan made me feel like
there was sincerely
no way out of this which made the
eventual strategies employed
all the more satisfying and ingenious to
me and the best part is
because isiama wanted to have two
separate battles happening on either
side of the wall at the exact same time
he was able to have his cake
and eat it too making both of these
brilliant climaxes work for
very very different reasons isayama told
us what to expect with erwin's plan
against the beast titan
and he kept armin's plan to stop
berthold largely
secret because of this i was able to
enjoy surprise and catharsis to the
highest of degrees
all within the run time of a single
episode erwin's plan not only doesn't
rely heavily on surprise it
actively pushes against it explicitly
telling the audience what his plan
is outright but strangely despite this
episode containing some of the best
action set pieces perhaps of the entire
franchise
the one part that i keep revisiting to
this day time after time
is this
soda i don't think any scene in an anime
so effectively placed me into the shoes
of its characters the way this one has
and if there was any scene i would not
want to be a part of it's this one as i
watch these poor soldiers shake
vomit and panic their way to their
deaths apart from the visceral approach
taken here i
really like how this scene contrasts
with armin's plan not necessarily in how
it's carried out but more so in how we
as an audience members participate
armin's mission is based entirely on
surprise we know how each of the
components work that make up how he
solves the eventual
issue however the ending of this is left
completely up to speculation this is
what makes this scene work
and when aaron finally reveals his big
revenge moment the sense of catharsis we
feel is made all the more powerful
because we didn't see
it coming this is the most accepting
aaron is of his current circumstances
within believing that reacting is the
best course of action right now
in other words this is aaron when he is
the most submissive to the world around
him
fully taking armand's advice in a battle
that you would think he has the greatest
potential for being
emotionally charged within aaron isn't
in control but
he seems to be okay with that working
alongside his team to achieve what they
need to
and contrasting that with the prior
section where his world comes crumbling
down around him as he finds out that
he's really nothing special
it makes for a wonderful comparison
however interestingly and also
in the same episode levi's assault on
the beast titan is almost entirely
forewarned
[Music]
they're not doing anything mechanically
revolutionary here
in shonen this is rather fundamental but
you'd be surprised how many screw up
this common shonen action trope or at
the very least
don't make full use of it thankfully
however attack on titan didn't fail but
instead presented to our eyeballs one of
the most decisive
and satisfying beatdowns ever
administered in the series but what did
it do right to make this so effective
well
it empowers us the viewers to some
significant extent and allies us with
the side we are most familiar with once
again to take dragon ball as an example
when
goku arrives right in the nick of time
to make the save during the ginyu forces
battle
toriyama utilizes dramatic irony so
effectively we know who goku is we know
what he's capable of and we know how
confident he is
and they have no idea what they're in
for similarly we as an audience have
seen
everything that levi can do how hard
he's fought and what he's lost
all building up to this one moment a
moment where zeke
doesn't know it yet but he's just made
the biggest mistake
of his life he underestimated levi
compounded by brief flashback sequences
where reiner and berthold even warned
zeke about levi
all this serves to make this beatdown
all the more satisfying for the viewer
or
reader and most importantly it only
worked because
we knew it was coming the levi battle is
built upon anticipation and the armin
plan
depends on suspense and surprise to be
successful both being incredibly well
executed it's a master class in the
fundamentals of shonen storytelling
demonstrating how and why these tropes
have become so effective and ubiquitous
within the shonen and broader anime
industry to harken back to the beginning
of this video where i drew your
attention to this particular quote from
pete doctor of pixar
he said it's that impossible struggle
with no answer that makes for great
stories
and you can tell that this episode's
subject matter connected with a lot of
people
due to the sheer amount of arguing that
manifested as a result of it
the debate over who ought to survey core
revive and inherit
berthold's titan armin the new promising
strategist or irwin the impressive
survey corps commander it's a
fascinating episode and discussion if
i'm being perfectly frank the value of
human life and the consequences of death
playing massive roles in this create
wonderfully engaging and emotional
outbursts from the likes of mikasa erin
and
even levi a robust litmus test i use to
gauge the competency of writing within a
series is how successfully they can pull
off interesting conversations for
extended periods of time there's a
phenomenal episode in re zero wherein
rem and subaru just talk
for the entire run time and it might be
my favorite episode from that series
shonen often leans heavily on action and
in some cases this can point to weak
character writing or a weak story
however by this point in attack on titan
the criticism that characters receive no
development or that the story is aimless
have to be thrown out the window
or at least i think they do because it's
impossible for so many people to be
sucked into a debate over a long
conversation with high consequences if
they didn't feel a connection on some
level to the characters that they stand
to lose here particularly after erwin
had given the performance of his life
this is a difficult pill for us all as
an audience to swallow we want people to
be rewarded for their efforts and to
one-up themselves later on
like they have done so often many ended
up disagreeing with their decision to
revive armin here however i thought
it was not only the correct decision but
the only one that they could have made
and i think isayama must have known that
too
one of the most irritating aspects of
dragon ball for many fans around the
world
is how it introduces establishes and
bonds us to
various characters over the course of
its story only to cast them to the
wayside later unceremoniously this is
what removing death as a consequence
does to a series
characters that serve a purpose need to
have an exit strategy otherwise they
become parodies of themselves
erwin's story was that of a tenacious
and courageous military leader
uncovering the secrets of the world in
the face of ridicule and impossible odds
and in the end he managed to lead that
world to the truth
a truth that he never got the chance to
see and right before he died
he made peace with that to me that
selfless act embodies erwin's spirit far
more than him discovering the secrets of
the world and soldiering onwards in a
hollow meaningless role thereafter could
possibly have done for him
had he discovered what was in the
basement he would have had no greater
purpose whereas armin
he still has a purpose the basement
imagine being so bold as to dangle a
carrot in front of your audience
promising them that it would be worth it
down the line
now imagine dangling that carrot for six
years now imagine that that carrot was
more astounding than you could have
possibly been prepared for
i've spoken numerous times throughout
this absurdly long video discussing how
isiyama managed to pull the wool over
our eyes in the name of subversions and
recontextualizing his characters
and world and this does all of that just
a lot better
the reveal that humanity beyond the
walls is not only still alive but also
thriving and far more technologically
advanced than we are
sounds like a convenient and somewhat
contrived twist made only to serve as a
diversion into the story's endgame
however nothing could be further from
the truth as we had
all the information we needed to predict
this ourselves before it was revealed to
us in episode 56
with hints dating back as far as episode
29 in season 2
a throwaway statement made in passing by
the scouts in an old castle details that
they discovered supplies likely left
behind by bandits recently however it
soon revealed that emir can read the
unfamiliar language on the canned
herring left behind
which is a saltwater fish these supplies
in question were left by the beast titan
who made an appearance just one episode
prior very close to this location
making it obviously not a coincidence
keeping these supplies in mind let's
look ahead to episodes 52 and 50
where we see zeke reiner and berthold
drinking coffee and the remains found by
armin of this camp show the coffee
grinder i mentioned
going back all the way to episode 29
it's clear to see that a similar
anti-coffee grinder was used in this
campsite the anime puts heavy emphasis
on this coffee grinder also placing it
in the warrior flashback in episode 35
the op of season 3's second part
and even giving it its own info card
this coffee grinder is of vital
importance to this mystery because
we know that coffee is a tropical export
with a short
shelf life meaning it cannot grow in
climates seen
in this series which frequently features
snow this explains why armin when he
discovers the campsite in episode 50
doesn't know what it is instead
referring to it as black tea
this tropical requirement of coffee
implies that where the warriors are from
has to be very far away from the land
within the walls or has access to it
through imports from other countries
explaining the presence of the now newly
imported coffee and the saltwater
herring through commercial fishing emir
is also a supremely valuable character
in this story for this sort of
exposition she describes the beast titan
as a monkey in episode 34 an animal that
aaron had never heard of before
once again due to the climate that they
reside within however as an audience we
know what a monkey is and therefore
never make the connection
the same goes for coffee and herring we
just never associated with anything
significant because
we know what it is and the characters
don't really need to tell us anything
furthermore it's made known to us that
humanity has been behind the walls for
107 years
with those in charge keeping technology
secret when we see merrily for the very
first time through grisha's eyes we are
met with the technologies placing marley
somewhere in the 1930s of our world
meaning the world within paradise
resembles that of a military nation from
the early 19th century which taking into
account the rivals we saw in season one
holds to be accurate so now let's take a
look at zeke
zeke makes numerous references to
baseball throughout his time with us
prior to the basement reveal however
what i didn't realize at the time was
that baseball as a sport was only
popularized in the mid to late 1800s
placing it far outside the scope of
paradise's understanding and once again
hints towards a more modern and
civilized outside world
this in addition to the numerous other
emir flashbacks the modern footwear worn
by zeke and berthold in episode 49 as
well as the countless talks concerning
grisha's modern medical abilities
saving everyone from a plague after
appearing miraculously outside the walls
one day
all paint a very clear picture once put
together of an outside world that is
both hostile and advanced
far beyond what they are capable of on
the inside and as an audience we were
all able to understand
all of that long before we saw that
photograph in the basement
but to tell you the truth of all the
reveals that shook my brain to its very
core
none did so more than that which made
this scene my favorite subversion in the
series
dina was the titan that came to kill
carla and was the titan that aaron
punched in making contact with her royal
body he was able to make use of the
coordinate power this wasn't a random
secret power but instead an example that
attack on titan sticks to its rules of
the world to such a degree
that my initial reaction to watching
this unfold before my very eyes
was probably something like this
in other words i liked it a lot and it
blew my mind so
i guess what i'm trying to say with all
of this is that what makes this basement
and this section as iconic and so widely
praised as it is
isn't just the photograph necessarily
but instead almost everything else that
came before it that made that moment and
that photograph make as much sense as it
ultimately did
and for most of us this recontextualized
the story into something we had not seen
before
no longer are we fighting titans instead
we are at war with humanity
outside the walls what does that even
mean
[Music]
behind the scenes season three while
season three's narrative content
particularly in its second half amounts
to some fans absolute favorite aspects
of the series this
ultimately marks a decline in the show's
production values in terms of its
average quality
despite containing arguably the best
pieces of animation the series has ever
seen
it unfortunately also had some
remarkably unfortunate lows
due to a deeply oppressive schedule and
some major staff omissions the troubles
with the schedule here cannot be
overstated while we now look back
at season 3 as a two-parter the show's
third season was never intended to be
divided in the first place when the show
first began it was listed for 22
episodes with the home release schedule
likewise reflecting this initial
broadcast time frame it wasn't until the
season reached its midpoint and the
network began to air unfinished scenes
again that
listing dates began to change and
ultimately the final episode of what is
now part one
concluded as per usual followed by a
hasty to be continued in part two
announcement perhaps the biggest example
of these troubles occurred within the
cave section of part one featuring
countless wonky drawings unfinished cuts
and missing directions such as camera
shake it continues beyond this episode
to an extent but no other section
features quite the same
many hundreds of corrections found on
the final home release
for things to melt at the first sign of
action it should come as no surprise
that an emergency mid-season break was
called for with the looming action-heavy
second half on the horizon
however with only six months between
parts with almost nothing but action
ahead of them the break could only do so
much and
unfortunately the second half of the
season struggled to keep together too
falling back on outsourcing in places
once again eventually fans noticed
what's become known as
meme tiles a repeated cut of animation
duplicated over and over and over again
to the point of hilarity masking the
lack of finished content
of course it also didn't help that even
the supervisors were struggling to
correct off model art in time for
broadcast too but all this schedule talk
aside one of the biggest losses in this
season came from the absence of the
makeup team that made such an impact in
season two
due to the production of the cabin area
of the iron fortress movie the team's
focus was entirely placed on said film
with no time left over to work on attack
on titan's third season for its dialogue
heavy first half which most definitely
would have benefited from the stunning
polish the team would provide
this is undoubtedly the biggest blow
felt this season
something that unlike unfinished
drawings missing a deadline isn't as
simple as just slapping the finished
work in the blu-ray miraculously however
season 3 is still widely regarded as a
fan favorite season with some of the
greatest pieces of animation and
direction
the show has ever seen it was an
undeniable success and the results speak
for themselves
so how was this even remotely feasible
given the horrific conditions i just
outlined well the answer boils down to
three major factors
tetsuro araki's wealth of industry
contacts the nurturing of emerging
in-house talent
and of course adifumi imai's unwavering
dedication to best his prior work
in the case of araki he realized very
quickly that for a dialogue-heavy
portion of the show to hold people's
attention it must be directed and
boarded to absolute perfection
if the narrative beats don't land if the
images aren't composed in interesting
ways
then everything quickly comes crumbling
down in the absence of animation to
remedy this he called back to his early
days at studio madhouse bringing on
board yoshiaki kawajiri of ninja scroll
fame alongside mamuro hosoda's pupil
tomohiko ito most well known for sora
online both of these individuals
provided competent storyboards for their
respective episodes along with them were
wit affiliates like takayuki hirao who i
mentioned earlier was an integral part
of the team
and joined by ryotaro makihara an
animator turned director with a
meticulous touch
together they formed a powerful team and
managed to alleviate the series key
moments
in ways that more than satisfied fans
and hid the trouble production the most
obvious examples of guest direction
elevating episodes comes in episode 46
in particular the very famous tokusatsu
director
friend of hideyakiano and co-director of
shin godzilla
shinji higuchi storyboarded this episode
and with him came toshiyuki sato the
wonderful guest animator i mentioned in
season 2
producing some horrifyingly natural
titan movement in other words in-house
talents were really coming up to the
forefront of the production and
strutting their stuff with impressive
finesse
sachiko matsumoto who was largely
unknown prior to this season hit fans
hard with her powerful animation of
erwin's demise
alongside the stunning effects driven
missile barrage as mikusa attacks the
colossal titan likewise another
relatively unknown talent by the name of
shinsuke aoki
delivered some wonderful in my inspired
work with several levi's scenes
and of course finally on the subject of
amay it would be absolutely impossible
to talk about this season without
mentioning this man's name
to say that he blew people away would be
an understatement of the highest order
his work on this section is both
inspiring and well legendary
storyboarding and animating his own
scenes in this season
the sheer number of man-hours put into
his contributions this time around paint
a picture of an animator both dedicated
to the franchise and
constantly looking to improve his
already magnificent skills
kicking off the first part of the season
in episode 2 with the absolutely
spectacular chase scene this 35 second
piece of animation
took am i an entire month to animate and
that was with the help from two
other people it is such a stunning piece
of work that wholeheartedly embodies the
journey the production of this show has
been on as it's come to perfect
the 2d 3d pipeline and continues to
iterate on the sheer
madness possible with it however there's
one major piece of animation that sticks
in people's minds when they think of
this season
a 45 second scene of legendary
proportions and one that has firmly
planted itself
as an all-time iconic fight scene in
anime
history it is of course levi versus
the beast titan this astonishing scene
is the result of
four months of hard work am i spent a
month alone on simply storyboarding this
sequence and then
another three months on top of that to
actually animate it and bring it to life
four months for 45 seconds and boy
was it worth it the three dimensionality
on display here is absurd beyond
description
levi shoots around down under and up and
what's so spectacular comparing this to
previous 2d 3d hybrid scenes is that
unbelievably background movement here is
2d
animated the consistency in form from
frame to frame as the
angle adjusts is just mind blowing
combined with the detail of the art the
complexity of the effects work and sheer
power of the animation's timing it's
really no surprise that this sits as one
of the most iconic scenes
around it is emblematic of attack on
titan's action and brought to life by
the very man that has defined it since
the very beginning
more than anything i think season 3 as a
whole could not be more of a perfect
send-off and summation of wit studios
time with attack on titan in spite of
horrific production conditions it shows
the power of a director's reach within
the industry and the sheer dedication of
its staff
as they work tirelessly to overcome the
odds it's the gathering of a monumentous
team
accumulated over years of work and shows
precisely what a tight-knit group of
individuals can do
under a leader with an unwavering vision
alas
with studio story ends here for now as
we head into
the mappa era for season four with any
sort of drastic change heads turn and
people pay attention we've seen as much
with the use of the makeup team in
season two it can be both very effective
and very jarring but one thing's for
sure
it will be noticed the transition from
with studio
to mapa is a complicated one one that
offers up changes in each and every area
and regardless of how you feel about the
change there's no denying it's certainly
gotten people talking
and paying much closer attention to the
production than ever before
to fully understand these changes it's
vital to get to grips with why this
occurred in the first place
with any anime a production committee
exists to organize and fund the
production and
ultimately reap the majority of the
rewards should the show be successful
with the original seasons the committee
consists of pony canyon who hold the
rights to the music
kodansha who owned the manga densu who
handled the advertising
mbs or nhk the relevant tv network
and finally production ig who as i
established earlier hold ownership over
whitfield the ig port banner when it
came to season four the committee as per
usual came to it and asked them to
tackle the season with the broadcast
dates set for late 2020.
in response to this with staff just
looked at their calendars and
it became very clear very quickly that
there was absolutely no way that they
could tackle this kind of a project with
the current time restraints
as much as they would have loved to have
done it it simply wasn't feasible and so
the committee were forced to look into
other studios and this is why me
outlining the production committee's
makeup is
important there's nothing there that
stops anyone from earning money by
changing studios no matter who ends up
taking on the project the committee
still wins
they asked every studio under the sun
and absolutely everyone was sane enough
to say
no to the demanding schedule being
offered to them except for one
studio mapper once a prestigious and
ethical studio led by masao muruyama of
ex madhouse fame his departure in 2016
led to a drastic change in the studio's
once meticulous approach
instead transitioning to more of a
conveyor belt company pumping out show
after show if you scroll through the
company's output you can see maruyama's
vision from 2012 to 2016
in full effect only producing two to
three shows a year
of largely very high quality after that
however
you can see the number of shows
ballooned with sporadic differences in
quality
with 2020 in particular seeing the
company produce eight
shows their agreement to take on the
project despite impossible circumstances
is both saddening and expected of the
company these days and with their
newfound place
on the committee the monetary gains for
its higher ups clearly outweigh the care
it has for its staff on the front lines
unfortunately in circumstances like this
the approach to creating anime becomes
very different where wit studio spent a
great deal of time assembling a team
auditioning character designers and
picking a director who would end up
gathering a powerhouse of strong
directors
mappa's approach was to grab whoever was
available
quite literally pulling new character
designer tomohirokishi
and telling him he'll be handling the
designs for the season fortunately
though for season four the little town
they could gather
certainly knew how to make an impact
taking over from tetsuro araki as series
director kem yuichiro hayashi another
mad house alumni who made his name at
mapa through his faithful and powerful
adaptations of series like gato and
doroge doro the latter of which was
praised heavily for its strong cg work
and stylish direction
aspects that became very important for
titan season 4.
this time however hayashi's role was as
chief series director meaning his work
was split with the regular series
director
john shishido who served the same role
in 2016's yuri on ice the division of
this role allowed the two to split the
workload and as a result
outside of a few episodes the pair
storyboarded the entire season
themselves
for a production struggling to assemble
core staff this is a real blessing and
frankly
there's a lot to be said about the level
of control and consistency achieved
through productions with a strong
singular vision now that's not to say
that season four is one big homogeneous
blob
remember ex jubilee member masayuki
miyaji who storyboarded the spectacular
10th episode of season 2
well miraculously he returned for season
4's 15th
episode producing the harrowing
presentation of zeke's backstory
although his work here doesn't have
quite the same level of visual oomph as
his last outing due to the weaker
accompanying director in overall
production
the episode is still a remarkable effort
filled to the brim with ambitious angles
and concepts on the in-house side of
things the in-house towns provided some
great work here too
teriyuki omine a very idiosyncratic and
ambitious
director worked on several pivotal
episodes oozing of atmosphere and impact
satoshi sakai from wit studio even
appeared on one of his episodes
and the one after and in episode 2 omine
requested the use of rotoscoping a
technique he first explored when working
on doroto's second ending
as a result the episode moved a lot and
featured a great deal of character
animation seldom found in the rest of
the franchise the execution is
a little janky to say the least but it's
hard to fault in a production starved of
specialist animators
unfortunately this lack of available
domestic talent is where the show starts
to drastically falter
you could write another two hour video
about the anime industry's problems here
but to put it simply
there are too many shows being made and
not enough staff to make them this
becomes an even bigger issue when you as
a studio are already taking on
too many shows for your own in-house
talent to handle let alone needing
freelancers the industry's solution
and one that mapa took in attack on
titan's case is to take to social media
and begin recruiting freelance animators
from overseas one such example would be
filipino animator ver creek who produced
one of the series coolest scenes there
were also chinese animators han han
and inklore who handled the levi vs
beast titan 2.0 fight which
is largely good but many of their rough
layouts were changed to 3d models due to
the lack of time to finish the 2d
drawings and that leads us to the big
elephant in the room here
the cg titans for a lot of people the
transition from 2d titan battles to 3d
was a tough one to stomach and it's been
a hot topic ever since the season
debuted understandably change can be
hard to come to grips with and
it's true that for many people cg of any
quality in anime will never hit
quite the same impact as its 2d
counterparts but in attack on titan's
case the cg is not only a dramatic
improvement from what came before
it's also arguably the most consistent
and strongest aspect within this
production from mappa taking over from
madboc the cg of season 4 is primarily
handled by studio v
syn a mappa affiliate and old
acquaintance of series director hayashi
the team's work on hayashi's previous
show doreje doro was justifiably praised
for its seamless blending of 2d and 3d
animation and it continues here in
attack on titan using 2d layouts for
reference the team makes full use of
traditional animation techniques like
frame modulation or frame cutting to
produce movements more akin to 2d
work likewise the texture work is
remarkably seamless
especially compared to madbox's video
game horror show
gun are the bizarre gradients instead
replaced by flat cell shading topped off
with a line work filter applied to the
2d animation to really bring
everything together with impressive
finesse it may not be as seamless as the
work found in studio triggers
productions but it's solid stuff
and was most definitely not deserving of
the hate directed its way upon broadcast
perhaps the most obvious and largest
change however this season admonishes
comes from the new character designs
while the previous character designer in
wit studio kyoji asano
had made many changes to his designs
over the years initially removing the
thick black outlines and eventually
slimming the faces and figures to age up
the characters the differences here are
even greater tomohirokishi took straight
to the manga fortunately dealing with a
very polished era of isayama's art and
translated
it rather directly to the screen for
example he consciously undid what he
considered to be overly sexy female
designs
saying that glossy lips and overt
sexiness don't really fit in the world
of attack on titan while this strong
adherence to the manga
is great for hardcore fans of the source
material it's unfortunately a little
less ideal for the animators that have
to draw them
not because of the nerfed women but
because they are immensely detailed with
hundreds of lines and particularly the
new movement gear that infamously
crushed the production with their
appearance
causing scenes to take three times as
long to animate
steps were made to alleviate this to an
extent for example the intense hatching
featured around characters eyes and jaws
in the majority of scenes aren't
actually hand drawn if you believe it
instead there are texture applied to a
drawing later down the line
saving animators many hours drawing
these details in
on the many thousands of frames each
episode it's a very smart way of going
about things and a method i'm sure
saved a lot of valuable time
frustratingly it's hard to talk about
season four's production without
sounding like you hate the show like
it's this irredeemable failure of a
continuation that must be condemned in
every way
i hope i didn't come across like that
because frankly
season 4 is still a perfectly enjoyable
entry to the franchise it's very lucky
in that the content it's covering has
next to no action and so the areas it's
not lacking in its directors and
storyboard artists can actually do a lot
to elevate the struggling production in
ways they absolutely wouldn't be able to
were this as action-packed as season 1.
with all that said
it is a season of compromise it's a
season of unfulfilled potential and most
critically it's a season of incredibly
overworked animators struggling
desperately to get things done on time
anecdotes from staff of having episodes
being incomplete less than 24 hours
prior to the air date corrections being
applied so late that you can see the
difference between the preview and the
final episode and heck even corrections
that straight up
don't get applied in time whatsoever the
story of this season's creation is one
wrought with misfortune and trade-offs
and one that yielded a less polished
product as a result however that's not
to say that this season didn't wow its
audiences at times
thanks in part to some solid visuals on
occasion but more so
the nail-biting heart-stopping and
soul-destroying narrative that consumed
my brain for weeks and weeks after
reading with the anime continuation not
hitting our screens until early 2022
one would hope the production can
stabilize in time until then
it's time to tackle this final quarter
of the story in its purest form
it's time for war
you might have noticed in the last
section concerning the basement that i
neglected to discuss
many of the other revelations and
elements found therein namely grisha's
backstory and the revelations of marley
this wasn't an unconscious mistake i
made in glancing over crucial material
instead it was a decision i made
intentionally to discuss the themes and
events found
and explore them within this section as
tonally i think it's a much more
appropriate fit considering the somewhat
controversial elephant in the room here
now while i'm sure a great number of you
have no idea that this has happened i'm
also sure a significant portion of you
may very well have skipped to this part
of the video
just to hear my impressions on this arc
and the controversy surrounding it well
over the last couple of years many
publications and discussions online have
labelled attack on titan as
pro-imperialist pro-fascist anti-semitic
and pro-war particularly after its most
recent arc
and the revelations found therein given
that my experience
is with story and that i do not espouse
to be politically savvy even in the
slightest i can only speak to what
impression i've received from the
narrative as a whole i'll do so briefly
as i'm sure politics aren't necessarily
why those of you that have watched this
far have decided to do so
concerning imperialism and the pro-war
propaganda some see in the story i don't
think i can get behind this particular
train of thought personally
visually the argument can be made that
battles are depicted as awesome and
something to admire
particularly with the driving force
behind the narrative being that of
nationalism early on
however this is done intentionally to
tear down those very concepts and themes
surrounding nationalism later
take the early opening sequences from
the show as an example of this
these can be seen as nationalistic
anthems depicting the flags and soldiers
of paradise as heroic
and in a positive light however over the
course of the series the tone of the ops
changes significantly
but slowly we learned through the series
that death is a horrific consequence of
this gallant heroism
and that these admirable soldiers are
all just people putting their lives on
the line
and what they stand to lose or risk by
joining the military is on full display
with even the colours at this point
having changed considerably to a much
darker tone
the atmosphere has changed and it's no
longer upbeat
however the changes continue as we
finally arrive at season 4's op
which depicts soldiers as mindless
zombies in a world devoid of life
and color with ruin around every corner
it actively depicts war as a negative
thing that begets more suffering and
that's just looking at the ops of this
story which
just so happened to mirror the
perspective of our main character aaron
jaeger throughout
naive to the truth of the world at first
aaron looked to the military as the only
ones worthy of respect to him
however over the course of the narrative
much like the various ops imagery have
shown
aaron's rose-tinted impression of the
military and war two fades as he
discovers the horrors of it and the
corruption
found even in the military by the time
he reaches marilyn in season four he's
become a completely different person
with
a very different yet resilient outlook
on life
this is all to say that while i do
believe that attack on titan focuses on
war and combat
i think it does so not by promoting any
pro-nationalistic message but by telling
a story about the horrors of war through
the lens of one character
aaron this would be different however if
the nationalistic tendencies he adopts
later in the story were projected in a
positive light also
however in this story aaron through
radicalization
becomes the villain his actions are
condemned both explicitly and
implicitly in the text and the same can
be said for both the jaegerists that
rise up with him
and marley at large in fact the entire
point of gabby's character is to show
that disliking or hating people for
traits that are otherwise out of their
control
is wrong that's the message or at least
it's the one that i received
now the conversation however becomes
much more muddy when we begin discussing
the anti-semitic criticisms of the story
to put it simply if looked at in
isolation
i do believe it's possible for someone
to get the impression from the story
that because the aliens had the capacity
to turn into monsters that the writer
might in fact be communicating something
equally nefarious about the jewish
people considering the allegory isayama
is using to communicate
that the aliens are akin to the jewish
people living under nazi germany
while i do think that this is an
understandable reading of events in
isolation i don't think it's due to any
insidious plan or prejudice against the
jewish community from the writer isa
yama
allegorically speaking drawing
comparisons like isiama has done here i
think
were an attempt to connect us with and
make us sympathetic to the plight of the
alien people by depicting them as
jewish people during world war ii
whether that be through the armbands
they wear the ghettos
they live in or through the treatment
they receive these easily identifiable
similarities are there to quickly help
us better understand their otherwise
complicated situation
without requiring the text to bloat
itself with detailed explanations
in storytelling oftentimes allegories
are implemented to connect us
emotionally with something that exists
in the real world already
george orwell's animal farm is a
textbook example of this
it didn't connect with people because
they enjoyed a story about farm animals
they connected with it because it
represented the danger surrounding the
russian revolution
in attack on titan hajime isayama
outlines clear and easily identifiable
similarities between the aldians and the
jewish people's treatment
and as an audience it immediately
encourages us to view merely as the
oppressive fascist and nationalistic
force
they are and the eldians the victims of
a horrid oppressor that needs to be
stopped
in other words the desired effect
isiyama wanted from this comparison he's
making
was to endear us to the elden warriors
sent to paradise and
to build a hatred for how marley has and
continues to
treat them in effect the story hinges on
isiama's ability to bridge the gap
between the audience
and the aldeans of marley that we have
been fighting against ever since the
story began
as an audience we need to like them for
the story to work or at the very least
sympathize with them this is what i
believe isiyama's intentions were for
the aliens to be akin to the jewish
people insofar as their treatment
and not a one-to-one comparison however
i cannot say that someone's
interpretation of the material is wrong
in this instance
if they think he's wrongfully implying
that the jewish community are monsters
taking all of this into account however
i think it's much more reasonable and
likely to assume that he was careless
with this particular allegory
and didn't intend for a story to be
received that way considering the main
message of the story is
anti-anti-semitism overall i personally
do not view attack on titan as an
anti-semitic fascist or pro-war
work but instead a cautionary tale on
the dangers of indoctrination
propaganda racism and perhaps most
interestingly
the path of suffering radicalization can
lead one down
with aaron's transition into the
antagonistic role the threat of the
titans as a whole
vanishes as both sides with their
nuances explored unite against a common
threat
isiama's handling of these subjects
might be a little clumsy
but it's fair in my opinion from
problematic if you look at the series in
its larger context
now with all of that addressed let's
finally dive into the story
the marley arc as i briefly touched upon
a moment ago the purpose for the
beginning of this arc is to endear us to
an enemy we've been fighting against for
the entire series
an enemy that's turned cities to rubble
torn families apart and terrorized
millions causing untold suffering across
not only the entire cast
but as we soon find out in the first
episode of the season
other parts of the world too trying to
successfully endear us to those
responsible for the destruction within
the walls seems impossible
but isa yama pulls it off it should go
without saying that this section shocks
and challenges its audience perhaps more
so than any other that's come before it
throughout this video i've given you my
enthusiastic musics on the first season
i've screamed in joy over the second
and i nearly passed out from the sheer
excitement during the prior season 3
material however
with this there is a very different
approach taken
and tone attempted to be struck instead
of following the same ragtag group we've
grown to love and appreciate since the
beginning isayama decides to deviate
from that by dragging us kicking and
screaming as we explore the other side
of this conflict
across the sea in a land called marley
redefining the meaning of the phrase a
cruel world through some
harrowing war-torn imagery within
moments isa yama had me
on their side the fourth season's
material is deliciously complicated and
nuanced
not complicated in that it's difficult
to follow but emotionally complex
primarily we bounce from new characters
oppressors victims warriors and even
children so much so that by the time the
third episode of this season rolls
around
it becomes clear that the real enemy
isn't the military hatred or
even the titans that we've been fighting
this entire time but instead
it's ignorance a fact that those in
power on both sides marley and paradise
to varying degrees
have utilized to oppress and control
their respective populations
i mean this is precisely why erwin
existed within the story and why the
entire cast
was so gung-ho on reaching shinganshina
and the basement in the first place
it was to discover the truth to become
less ignorant
conversely on the other side of the
conflict in marley we see this theme
explored to its natural extreme
the indoctrination of the youth
brainwashing them into not only
believing that they themselves are devil
spawn but that it is their duty to die
formerly and to repent for these
inherent sins
they supposedly have and so when i
discovered we weren't going to be
following the point of view of the
scouts but instead the up-and-coming
recruits and forces from marley instead
i without any word of hyperbole jumped
for freaking joy at this point i hadn't
decided to read ahead in the manga and
still had no clue how the story was
intending on proceeding however electing
to show us that the enemies we've been
fighting against
all this time aren't monsters but people
trying to stay alive too was exactly the
sort of injection of narrative ambiguity
and moral nuance
i was expecting from this tale and boy
was i happy
gabby gang gabby gang gabby gang gabby
gang gabby gang gabby gang gabby gang
wheeze of the battlefield too smart got
a big brain but a bigger heart
this is exactly why i found gabby to be
such a tremendously well-written
and important character to help
introduce us to the indoctrination and
propaganda rampant in the world of
marley
she's single-minded well-trained and
filled with hate
reminding us that unlike the audience
the characters in the story are ignorant
and easily manipulated all in the name
of seizing power
from marley
this is where the relentless pursuit of
power leads us to a world that can turn
the most compassionate of children into
monsters
and a defenseless child into a heartless
attacker
aaron and reiner despite being at each
other's throats for the majority of the
story are actually remarkably
more the same than they are different a
cursory glance back over the story
particularly after the material covered
in the season
demonstrates that both reiner and aaron
have a threshold for suffering that far
exceeds most if not everyone in this
tale they each go through torment and
tremendous loss for their respective
goals
somehow finding the resolve to do so
along the way unlike other characters
that often crumble in the series
aaron chooses freedom over comfort and
reiner too chose in the face of absolute
failure and horror
he kept pushing forward now i spent a
considerable amount of time towards the
beginning of this video discussing and
exploring how and why aaron's character
works within the story explaining that
he's an
active protagonist trapped in a world
that forced him to be reactionary and i
bring this up again because
reiner on the other hand is a
reactionary character living in a world
that forces him to be active
aaron a sword forced to defend and
reiner a shield
forced to attack both of these
characters while in verses of each other
share a desire that no matter what we
deserve better reiner is fighting in the
hope that one day he will be the hero
that will raise the eldian people
standing in the world
and aaron is fighting for the freedom of
humanity they are both the protagonists
on each of their respective sides of
this wall
and ironically if that very element to
their personalities that they have in
common that leads them to be mortal
enemies
great friends and ultimately the reason
this entire story is being told at all
and if you're thinking the similarities
between these two characters ends here
you'd be dead wrong in the beginning
both reiner and aaron believed that they
were inherently special that something
inside that made them worthy of all this
bloodshed failure and suffering that
they've caused
on their way towards this ultimate goal
however as i pointed out in the prior
section
aaron has an existential crisis after he
sees
that the only reason he was able to
transform in the first place was due to
his father forcing it upon him after
killing the rhys family brutally
and as we discover in this section
reiner was the worst warrior trainee
only receiving his special qualities
because marcel
influenced and manipulated the higher
ups into choosing him there's a
phenomenal and superbly written video
dissecting this very relationship i'm
discussing between
reiner and aaron called two sides of the
same coin
by the youtube channel's soul and in it
he points to a specific panel from the
manga that perfectly captures reiner's
character succinctly
and it does so because in this image
reiner's reality and delusion
stand in stark contrast side by side
i will save everyone he says as he
abandons marcel i'm going to punish the
ireland devils despite acting like more
of a devil than any of the aldens he's
demonized
i'm going to become a hero he says
killing thousands of innocents and
failing his mission through this
flashback we can clearly see that not
only is reiner running away from this
titan but
he's running away from his problems from
a mother who's manipulative
and delusional and a father who despises
him and
interestingly it's this coping mechanism
this distancing himself from dealing
with who he really is
that creates instances where reiner at
times
seemed to be innocent and good earlier
in the series
much like aaron shown in hero
personality being at odds with the rest
of the world
reiner has his own shonen hero persona
that too is at odds with reality and so
when marcel gets eaten after saving
reiner the leader and best candidate
among them
reiner is forced to hide in his delusion
and press forward with his mission to be
the hero that he thinks he's meant to be
and in doing so realizes that the people
he's been taught to hate his entire life
are just
regular people like him back home and
ironically enough
it's through his embodiment of this
delusion that he becomes the person he
always wanted to be
in paradise someone strong reliable and
someone people can look up to
until he snaps now years later all he
can do is suffer the consequences of his
actions in
total depression he made fatal mistakes
that others have had to pay the price
for
and he never became the hero he thought
he was destined to be
if you ever needed evidence of dramatic
character development and attack on
titan
look no further than right here in this
scene from season four
having once demonized him as a traitor
he vowed to kill aaron now sees the
humanity in reiner while reiner someone
who constantly ran away to protect his
sanity
is now forced to face the living
embodiment of his past
sins and aaron now moments before he
commits mass genocide
probes reiner to see if he will be able
to live with it like he has
will he be able to accept it in this
moment
aaron acknowledges that they are very
much the same
this is the biggest shift in the entire
series from a character standpoint
after following aaron's struggle as an
active protagonist forced to bend to the
will of the cruel world
aaron finally has the agency he so
desperately yearned for and in achieving
such
killed countless innocents becoming the
villain of this series
itself then on the other side of the
coin after admitting to the sins of his
past for the first time aloud and
bending his knees to aaron before him
reiner begrudgingly becomes the hero
of this story the sword that was once
defending is now
attacking and the shield that was once
forcing itself to attack
is now defending those that need
protection the attack titan
and the armor titan are now in their
natural states
so let's dance naturally it's around
this time i simply couldn't wait for the
anime any longer and picked up the manga
to read ahead in the series because
this fight may very well be my favorite
from a thematic standpoint
for what it represents in the series
it's such a strong and clear mirroring
of the events in shigen shina with gabby
as an appropriately headstrong stand-in
for aaron as he becomes the monster he
once despised
i mean there's a reason why they
composed the poster of season 4 to look
like this
because it mirrors the very first one
and the fight that takes place is one of
the most
dominant and adrenaline pumping outings
from isoyama while being much more
narratively focused on the subtext of
the heinous actions from aaron it also
sports some truly
hellish visuals and graphic scenes and
can we take a moment to talk about how
awesome peck is during this figuring out
what was happening
enabling her to make the save with porco
in the middle of an
enemy sneak attack there's some
tremendous action here the back and
forths are stupendous but no moment from
this fight for me
outshines the appearance of the scouts
seeing them suddenly and slowly begin to
make themselves known is both an
exhilarating and terrifying experience
in this season
climaxing with a beautifully delivered
quote by porco
as haunting as it is pathetic while the
soldiers from paradise begin surrounding
him
can't you see i'm a titan these guys are
just humans yet
they're coming to kill me these guys
they're the devils of paradise
it's such a horrific scene that builds
beautifully and makes out the forces of
paradise to be
every bit as terrifying and monstrous as
they've been warned they were
and yet as an audience we know that not
to be true
there are so many mixed emotions
implications and consequences from this
battle and in real time
i found myself reeling just trying to
grasp the scope of this event
all the while gabby is forced to watch
her friends get trampled to death
or killed quickly and suddenly by the
devils from paradise just like aaron was
forced to do
all those years ago however unlike aaron
gabby
is different she can do something about
it
war for paradise arc it was clear for
me at least while i was watching all of
this suffering unfold that we were
finally entering the endgame
of this story for sasha who had up until
this point being such a positive force
to not only have to participate but
to die suddenly and unceremoniously
because
of this fighting it made me feel well
conflicted to put it bluntly in one way
i felt it appropriate the cynical
direction aaron chose to take the story
and meant that positivity had to take a
backseat and so
thematically it felt as though the joy
of the series had died also
the one person that was always looking
to the future with optimism now
no longer has a place in this cruel
world and
unlike what felt like at the time the
entire internet
i didn't hold gabby entirely responsible
i loved sasha as a character but those
actions gabby took were a retaliation
against an aggressor she'd been raised
and trained to hate her entire life
and ironically due to the way we follow
their journey from this point on both
gabby as well as falco represent the
future of this world
twisted as their views once were it's
their journey in the pursuit of truth
that makes for me
the most narratively compelling portion
of this upcoming final part
to the anime i don't think it's
coincidence that this section of the
story contends and deals with the
radicalization and de-radicalization of
two
very similar characters but at very
different times in their lives
aaron and gabby obviously the stand-in
for erin during the raid of liberio
gabby is placed in a position of
contempt amongst the viewership all the
while we're more inclined to hope for
and forgive the demonstrably larger
scale of suffering
aaron has unloaded on these people due
to our long-standing relationship with
the character however
as aaron unrestrained pushes himself
further and further astray
gabby well she starts to change
and for complete transparency i wasn't
exactly surprised by the direction her
character was taken in it made perfect
sense to me for her to serve this
purpose to push gaby's ideals and
prejudices to the absolute limit
until her worldview is shattered leaving
her forced to finally contend with
reality finally starting to see clarity
past the ignorance that once clouded her
mind
all of this is perfectly good but it's
how isoyama got us to that point that i
thought was the most brilliant and
surprising aspect of it proving it's not
the destination but the journey that
changes
minds and no solitary episode better
exemplifies that progression or
journey than this one episode 70
entitled deceiver
it's just it gives me the good chemicals
i could go on and on about the gorgeous
storyboard this episode boasts or how it
massively endeared me towards the
character of falco but
in truth the main reason why i loved
this episode came down to how it used
the gabby character
to fully explore what radicalization can
mean and how the greater story played
into this message
being amplified substantially now i
touched on this briefly in the season 2
section of this review but the episode
where sasha rescues a little girl
from a titan stood as one of the
highlights of that arc for me taking a
character that once held onto a
prejudice concerning outsiders and
turned her into a strong hero that saved
an innocent and that very innocent
helped to save gaby
and falco all the while confronted them
about their hatred for her people
and we know gaby is the one that kills
sasha the girl that saved her
and she doesn't even know about that god
i'm getting worked up just talking about
this one i love this episode the
messaging of the story here is fantastic
obviously the script is great but
it's what's not being said that almost
makes the most noise
on this occasion for me the expressions
falling across gabby's face
as her world comes slowly crashing down
around her the sobering realization that
everything she's been taught
might actually be a lie it's one of the
most cathartic conversations in the
series but
you know what's not cathartic
remember when i said that this story was
deliciously complicated and nuanced
well this is what i meant one it's
obvious to everyone that flock
is a hell spawn that deserves a fiery
death more painful than i could possibly
describe it's also shown to us how and
why he came to feel this way
this now radical leader of the agaris
forces doesn't just sprout
out from thin air like almost everything
else in this story
it does so after the appropriate time
and buildup all the way back in the
prior season we can all plainly see the
seeds for this sort of corruption being
present it's all there his fear his
hatred his
punchable face it's there plain as day
he believes in a nationalistic vision
for the future and those thoughts were
nurtured accidentally through the
earnest efforts of one hanji and the
forces of paradise
as they over the course of four years
strove for a peaceful resolution and
integration into the broader world
and while aaron is a big part of this
entire movement and i do fully intend on
talking about our man that's one with
the man bun i thought the dynamic hanji
zou provided
acted as the best narrative opposing
force to flock's cruel overly
nationalistic view in the story with her
insisting that finding a peaceful
resolution is the only worthwhile
pursuit for a better tomorrow but
situations are complicated and watching
as hanji is forced to withhold
information from the people
she promised she wouldn't lie to ever
again hurts
but again we can understand why she's
making those decisions
making all of these characters not only
feel flawed but
much more real after the amazing fight
and aftermath on the rate of liberio
finishes
the story sort of takes a pit stop in
expositionville
and spends a night or two in the
flashback hotel it's not my favorite
part of the story but i can see why it's
needed and i'd rather it be there than
it not
and this is vital for two reasons it
helps us better
hate flock with the burning intensity of
a thousand sun
and it helps us set up and build tension
as we press forward into the climax of
the story as an audience we know that
there are so
so many enemies on route to paradise
wanting to clap back
after what happened and so what
initially started as a frustrating
annoyance within the military and public
questioning why aaron was apprehended in
the first place it eventually and
naturally turns
into a full-blown movement to overthrow
the scouts and free aaron
this very much is the final setup phase
of the story and isiama doesn't want to
screw anything up and so while it might
be a little pedantic with some of the
characters and episodes as we discuss
foreign policy with
not japan or build a railroad it's also
filled with meaningful character moments
alongside some intensely interesting and
heartbreaking events
until it too reaches a boiling point
jeez dude watch this lise you can
actually pinpoint the second when his
heart rips in half
and now this was one of the hardest
scenes to sit through particularly in
the manga the way isayama drew miku's
face during this exchange is honestly
heartbreaking with armin surprisingly
and sufficiently carrying a lot of the
emotional
weight here too if you cast your minds
back to episode one of the series armin
chooses not to fight the bullies for he
believes much like he does now if he
were to fight back
it would be stooping to their level this
speaks to his philosophy in pursuing a
peaceful means of integrating within the
world
he sees retaliation and violence as
stooping to their level and while aaron
was talking down to him specifically for
a considerable portion of this he held
himself still the same way he would when
facing any other bully however he cracks
when aaron rips mikus's heart to pieces
it's a gut-wrenching scene and
i haven't even begun to talk about levi
zeke's betrayal of marley and levi's
supervision of
him stands as the only moment in recent
memory where attack on titan actually
made my heart sink into my stomach
as a strong wave of insight and sudden
realization cascaded over my body
the utilization of the wine to infect
all of the unsuspecting aldeans with
zeke's spinal fluid was
something i never saw coming and found
deviously clever
it's already been established that the
titan formula needs to get into the
bloodstream and alcoholic beverages work
by transporting the alcohol
into the bloodstream all the
foreshadowing pieces were there
including a really strange altercation
at a restaurant with sasha's boy toy
it's such a terrific adherence to the
mechanics of the world while still
managing to pull a surprise
out of what felt like thin air creating
one of the most tense moments i had ever
experienced while reading through a
story
and perhaps because this was a scene i
experienced in the manga first
i actually didn't enjoy it nearly as
much in the anime when i saw this panel
i felt as though that was it for levi it
felt to me that a death here
could be tragic and serve to create more
tension leading into the climax later
and so in other words
as i was reading through this i
literally convinced myself that he was
done for
but you gotta be kidding me
styles and the beast titan and drags his
stubby ass
into a cart i firmly believe my
preference for this
is squarely a result of me reading the
manga first and in the anime it's a
great adaptation for the most part and
then we get
zeke's flashback at this point in the
story we're made fully aware of zeke's
motivations to work alongside aaron but
what i like the most about zeke's
portrayal is that
much like everything that's revealed in
this series it's foreshadowed
numerous times during the lead-up to
this flashback plenty of personnel have
remarked at how
special zeke is but never outing his
royal blood as the reason
and simply put it's because he never
told them
now it's very possible that that reveal
wouldn't have landed for me had i been
reading week to week but i
binged this series hard and caught up in
like two days at chapter like 137 so
look i was completely surprised when i
saw zeke as a traitor to marley but
when i saw what the plan was things got
extremely serious and
real very quick with him having the
means to enact his plans seemingly at
the ready
all he needs to do is
which brings us to here the
end of the anime with the two
protagonists from either side reiner and
aaron facing each other once again for
what will no doubt be a battle to decide
the future of this world
it's the perfect point to leave off this
story but a ridiculous cliffhanger
considering
what i know comes next but as you know
this is where the anime chose to go on a
mid-season break i will henceforth be
covering material as of yet not adapted
by the anime so
if you wish to avoid spoilers and have
watched this far i would like to say
thank you so much for watching and i
hope you'll come back
to visit once the series returns
all right those that care about
supporters are gone now thank god i
wasn't sure how much longer i could go
without mentioning a spoiler like the
rumbling
or the weird centipede thing or aaron's
head being blown off but
now i'm amongst those that don't mind so
let's press on forward
to tell you the truth the rumbling is
the single most terrifying action set
piece
i've seen committed to the pages of any
manga and going into this final section
on paradise i found myself reflecting on
the beginning of this arc quite a lot
the motivations surrounding aaron are
honestly unsettling to say the least
not just because of what manifests from
them but because the story has been told
from aaron's point of view for pretty
much its entire run
if you think back across the attack on
titan story it's all pretty much
following aaron's journey
and story surrounding his origin however
that's not the case in
season four one of the first things we
notice about the arc is that we're
following a different perspective
and the first time we see aaron is as an
intruder or outsider to the narrative
the manga and the anime frame this scene
to show aaron as the villain or
antagonist
he interrupts the narrative and reigns
destruction down upon those around him
many of whom are innocent however what
makes it scary to me at least is that
over the course of the act we're shown
his thought process the conflicts in
liberia the uprising of the egoists
the battle of paradise afterwards and of
course the rumbling
are all metaphors for how conflict
manifests in the real world and the
horrible outcomes that can stem from
them what began as a story about a boy
and his friends fighting against what
was understood to be an
absolute evil outside the walls was
eventually revealed to be a
desperate and conflicted assault from
some brainwashed and abused children
acting on behalf of a tyrannical
government across the sea the story
became
so much more complicated and nuanced
aaron spent years of his life looking
for an alternative to war with marley
and all his efforts in attempting to do
so went out the window the instant
marley themselves
declared war on paradise fully intending
on slaughtering
all of them in order to take what they
want for themselves
and much like those living in shigen
china that faithful day in the beginning
the civilians of marley and people like
gabby will only see aaron as
a pure evil maniac acting on his
inherent devil nature
aaron's attack on liberio while i
believe it was coming anyway happened
there and then because
that's where marley declared war on
paradise his attacks were targeted
against marlene officials and
sponsors after the declaration was made
the current plan being worked on by the
likes of hanji armin and the rest of the
scouts through
foreign politics were hinging on a
reality that was founded in fantasy
much as it pains me to say but
pretending like they could have waited
50 years to become part of some
international trade and political sphere
becomes nigh impossible when we consider
the broader context that marley was
formulating a plan of action against
them long before they could have reached
that goal not to mention rally support
from the rest of the world and spread
propaganda concerning the aliens of
paradise
this of course isn't to say that i
support aaron's efforts here
absolutely not but there's a big
difference between supporting aaron's
rumbling and
understanding that after this
aforementioned point it's either a
question of succeeding in a monstrous
war effort for your entire country or
letting them die for the benefit of a
foreign elite and that's the terrifying
reality of this story the notion that
sometimes
in very very serious life-threatening
situations
there are no clear or straightforward
answers available
both choices are hard aaron understands
that the only way for him to make
paradise free
is to win a war against the entire rest
of the world
and the rumbling is the only weapon they
have with which to achieve
that on the other side of the coin the
hero forces whom we follow the point of
view of are comprised of oppressors and
oppressed alike
from all sides of this conflict coming
together deciding to sacrifice their own
people to ensure the survival
of a far greater number understanding
that if they succeed
the oppressors will massacre and oppress
ruthlessly
and without reluctance most likely and i
think that's what makes this final
section of attack on titan so
intense and heart-stoppingly captivating
it's why i've spent what is now over 60
pages of a script writing about it and
i'm sure it's why a number of you have
been watching all of this time too it's
a clashing of ideals in a situation
where each ideal is forced
logically to its most extreme
conclusions there is no pure evil doer
or wholly correct hero
and there is no way out of this
situation that doesn't end in
significant
and tragic loss on both sides there's
only trade-offs available here and
having to face that as a reader felt
horrific horrific because that's the way
the world
is and it forces you to contend with
that reality
chapter 126 and 127 are supremely
powerful i think because it forces our
new hero team
if you can call them that to sit during
the night and contend with what lies
before them and what the give and take
of the upcoming situations
are a strong highlight for me has to be
how hanji much like her commander before
her gave up her life to give our heroes
a chance at effectively saving the world
from aaron's
wrath made all the more effective by its
aftermath as she finds herself in the
paths alongside
all those she's lost it's a powerful
moment made all the more so by how often
throughout this series hanji has second
guessed herself and how much of the
blame she
shoulders herself for this event
happening she's been a massively
optimistic character and the perfect
choice to succeed erwin i think
she's had to contend with learning that
titans were once people that she
experimented on and tortured she's had
to deal with tremendous loss and she's
had to deal with letting people down
time and time again like everything else
in this series it's a bummer but
she's optimistic for a better tomorrow
until the bitter end with a supremely
powerful panel seeing her exclaim
i'm not accepting genocide she values
life she recognizes that there are
innocent and defenseless people
all over the world so in other words she
wants to protect humanity
not just her humanity in paradise but
all of it and all of this came before
the big storm that eventually erupts as
they conflict the very end
this piece before it gave me pause to
consider and cast my mind back to
appreciate all the hidden hints
foreshadowing this very event
whether it be exactly talking to aaron
during his trial in season one about
either being a demon
of destruction or a savior there are two
instances with armin one where he chats
with jean about the titans they
discovered in the walls potentially
going for a walk or
armin again remarking that aaron always
runs off on his own leaving them behind
during the season 2 material
heck even the way aaron justifies his
killing of the human traffickers to
protect mikasa might help explain how he
dehumanizes those that might threaten
paradise in the wider world he thinks of
them as
animals threatening the freedoms of
himself and his loved ones
and so keeping all of these in mind as i
look on watching as
aaron marches like some sort of eldritch
nightmare across the sea and arrives
on the mainland as a reader i'm just
faced with the suffering and terror that
this sort of force brings to the world
now before i move on to the final battle
i have to shout out this amazing artist
and creator on youtube called
kane pixels they've gone out of their
way to recreate some of the major story
beats from attack on titan's final
section
in a found footage news report style
from the 1940s or 30s it's
amazing and terrifying check it out okay
time for the big bad oh wait no okay
wait no first thing oh geez levi how
could i forget levi
okay so levi is alive the scene where
his body is discovered by hanji
the way it's framed or worded and the
way the scene cuts short in my heart of
hearts i knew there was a good chance
levi was alive
chapters and chapters and chapters
passed on by
and no levi until suddenly levi's alive
i was so pumped now naturally i didn't
have the same build up like some of you
guys might have had i mean i blitzed
through pretty much
all of the prelude to the rumbling and
the battle thereafter
in a couple days but even then i made a
lot of really weird and loud happy
noises as soon as my brain processed
what happened levi
you absolute monster and human wrecking
machine you
are alive okay now it's time for what i
thought was the most hyped thing i've
ever seen
the final battle but first a small
disclaimer something i noticed that
happened to me anyway when i was part of
a community surrounding a long-running
franchise
was that eventually i became less
flexible to what the author or products
were delivering in other words i
didn't like it as much now plenty of
people haven't liked the last few
chapters of attack on titan and
i'm sure it's for very justifiable
reasons but i can
say that i had that same experience
personally i love them so if you're one
of those people who didn't like it i'm
sorry that you didn't but
i can't speak to your experience i could
only speak to my own so with that out of
the way
let's dive in truth be told usually when
i write about a given section i like to
write out the bullet points of what i
think
makes it tick so i can better structure
my arguments or observations concerning
it thereafter
but with this there's there's just too
much
it's fittingly the culmination of most
of the present characters arcs
as well as the send-off to the series
jean acts as the selfless hero armin the
assertive strategist gabby is
de-radicalized and aiding the effort
levi
in devastating fashion completes the
last ever mission erwin ever gave him
peck-styled like only the karak titan
can and mikasa overcame her greatest
weakness
and that's not even to make mention of
the scale this battle boasts from a
visual standpoint i need only point to
one of the many big page spreads to
demonstrate the astounding progression
isa yama has made as an artist
over the last 11 years of publication i
mean who knew consistent practice could
make you amazing this
entire fight is packed with so much
content that honestly
i think i could write another two hour
video alongside detailing the conflicts
and consequences that emerge
from this mega man-esque showdown
against the villains of the past
so for the sake of compromise let's talk
about my favorite aspects of it and why
i thought they worked as well as they
did
for me and maybe a thing or two that i
didn't like
okay first things first the paths how
they work and how they're depicted
before
leading up to and during this battle
served to amplify the story greatly for
me
impressing me further by how everything
here makes sense because
everything has been slowly built up to
over the course of a hundred plus
chapters
if you told me in 2013 that little kid
aaron would be the living embodiment of
all my greatest fears both physical and
existential all made possible through
the power of titan path blood magic i
would have said
you're crazy and i'm not watching this
story the paths and how they connect
different parts of this story are
visually stunning and serve to
bring everyone together for tons of
meaningful scenes whether it be the
ambush that zeke tries to get aaron with
only for him to reverse uno card the
bearded blondie and say
actually no i'm ambushing you one of the
best moments with the pats has to be how
aaron announces to all the alien people
both in paradise and throughout the rest
of the world that
the rumbling is happening that honestly
gave me shivers and made the occasion
feel
all the more massive and hopeless this
is peak titan magic and it's so
out there and crazy yet feels so
perfectly connected and justified
and not at all silly when in the context
of attack on titan's world and during
this battle the paths play an integral
role in the functionality of this
i mean look at this armin gives zeke a
feels bad man speech
only it's actually really nice and not
at all city like i'm describing it and
he pops out like a pimple on prom night
from aaron's founding titan body like
i love how this all makes sense but out
of context it could be the weirdest
thing anyone could have seen that week
and levi has no chill at all by the way
dude barely gets a few words out and
levi eviscerates him from existence
jokes aside though i thought this moment
was great and the reason why is painted
across levi's face
after he does the deed erwin wanted him
to take out the beast titan a threat to
humanity
but in making himself visible zeke found
the beauty in being
alive and so while levi did take out his
target at the same time he didn't
the zeke that he was assigned to take
out was long gone
i mean geez not even levi gets to be
happy the way that he wanted to
and the battle that takes place might be
one of the best i've seen
in fiction as i mentioned prior there
are so many individual moving parts to
consider
each with their own motivating factors
and distinct goals now with something
like this i was terrified that it could
get extremely messy and convoluted very
quick
but right from the outset we are given a
goal and that soon becomes a two-part
plan and then a three-part plan and then
the plan suddenly becomes a monument to
how screwed they all really are
this was one of the coolest aspects of
this tale there's honestly tons to love
about this part of the story but
that's not to say that i'm in love with
everything it has to offer
if there's one aspect to this finale
that i'm lukewarm on it's
the titan centipede thing but that's not
to say that i don't think it makes sense
at least not any less than a tree of
life does in norse mythology it's like
the existence of god in the bible
it's this source of life that in the
series's case kicks off the story in
amir's flashback giving her the power of
the titans and spawning everything that
happens
after that zeke even goes as far as to
liken it to the god particle more or
less in that it's
this mysterious entity that happened to
survive among the matter that vanished
however i do think there's criticism to
be made here nevertheless
this is a story where pretty much every
character and element found therein has
been
massively fleshed out and the byproduct
of that is a story where you could
effectively drag
every alien in the world to a google
hangout in the paths
and it doesn't come across as silly or
ill-fitted with how character-driven
everything is
a more nebulous concept like this
centipede that's
external to the story and not really
acknowledged by anyone directly
can feel a bit i don't know
underwhelming it's a very important
figure that isn't expounded upon
in masses of detail so its importance is
quite easily overlooked and
as a result kind of makes its appearance
in the finale a little lackluster if
you're not 100 glued to every sentence
the manga throws at you
however with that said aaron colossal
titan fight with armin
as aaron's rumbling is put on hold and
he has to dedicate all of his energy to
contend with armin's colossal titan
all eyes fall to mikasa as she needs to
make the final move here to decide
what way she's going to go about this
something i will say about this though
is that for reasons
some of which i've outlined in this
video mikasek comes across as so much
more interesting and likable in the
manga tragically much of what has been
cut to allow for adequate anime pacing
has been an element to her character
that brought her to life for me
and made this moment feel all the more
impactful and for that reason among many
others
i am happy that i started reading the
manga when i did in preparation for this
video
it made this chapter significantly so
much more powerful and
immeasurably heartbreaking and as i
watched mikasa now for the final time
sore through the air and into the mouth
of aaron's colossal founder
my heart stopped as i watched mikasa
sever the head of the person she loves
more than anyone else in the world
followed by a kiss i will sincerely
never forget
both horrific and beautiful in its
depiction an action that perfectly
captures
attack on titan's soul allowing isa yama
to make his biggest and farthest
reaching callback
he's ever made in this series see you
later aaron
echoing the opening words from chapter
one over 11 years ago
i get chills just thinking about it
however perhaps more likely to be
overlooked has been one of the most
ironic potential foreshadowings i
noticed while re-watching the series in
my research for this video in episode
5's conclusion aaron says
much like he does in the manga you think
i'm going to die in a place like this
as he stands in the mouth of a titan
with his desire to protect his friend
and to fight for what he believes in
being the very reason he found himself
in that specific position in the first
place and now over 130 chapters later
we find ourselves at the end of this
long twisting story
again with aaron through his intense and
unyielding desire to protect what he
cares for
places himself in a place like this
all of his own creation forcing his
loved ones hands
to do the unthinkable god i love this
story
alright guys a small disclaimer before i
move on to my final thoughts surrounding
this series i'm actually recording this
the day the video comes out because it
turns out chapter 139
came with a lot more baggage than i was
anticipating while i think in broad
strokes the next paragraphs to this
video surmise my overall thoughts and
impressions on the series
and its ending to some extent i've
decided that it's necessary for me to
give my full and more complicated and
critical impressions of it
once official translations become
available for chapter 139
so for now enjoy my final thoughts on a
series which i wrote prior to the full
chapter dropping and anticipate a more
detailed video on the final chapter and
my feelings surrounding it
next week thanks and that's when we get
it
the last chapter 139 i knew that going
into this it would be mostly clean up on
the details and aftermath of the prior
chapters aftershocks
but something did surprise me here
having been a story that's encouraged me
to think instead of feel
all of this time for the last chapter
all i could focus on while reading was
my now long history with this series
after eight years of personally keeping
up with it sharing it with family and
discussing it long into the wee hours of
the night with my closest friends
i'm confronted with the reality that
attack on titan
is over like any great story worth
telling i am somewhat sad to see it go
but
overcome with joy that the author got to
tell the story he wanted to share with
us
in its entirety a story detailing the
dangers of racism
ignorance and radicalization all while
demonstrating that sometimes
much like real life there are no
clear-cut right answers for
any side only trade-offs the muddied or
messy messaging many began to criticize
this series for brandishing
while it might not be for everyone for
sometimes understandable reasons
for me i think it helped to capture the
muddy and messy nature of global
politics and
humanity at large without compromising
towards a deus ex machina type
contrivance
that points to an obvious world peace
solution when in reality something like
that just doesn't exist
it's sad it's controversial and
sometimes
incredibly disheartening and while it
concludes in this fashion
i think it does so while leaving behind
a gentle yet hopeful echo
one that reminds us that yes terror may
create cruel people
pacifism may lead to suffering and love
can lead to heartbreak but we shouldn't
lose hope for the possibilities the
future might bring
for despite everything i've mentioned
there's a reason why we love
why we believe and why we continue to
fight
until the bitter end
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you